Hallo herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim und es mal wieder eine woche rum ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ganz eine woche.
Aber wir haben uns heute heute den einundzwanzigsten april zwanzig die waren diese tage.
Die nennung der der tages daten so wichtig ja wieder zusammengefunden ich und pavel hallo pavel.
Denn wir wollen wieder zusammenfegen was ich denn so in der letzten woche ergeben hat rund um die zahlen welten in denen wir derzeit so leben von infizierten toten kranken fall raten sterblichkeitsraten legalität,
modalitäten das werden wir heute alles nochmal ein bisschen genauer umdrehen zumal zu gerade darum auch im nachgang zu unserer letzten sendung und auch in der öffentlichen diskussion eine ganze menge
konfusion gab und wie ich finde auch immer noch gibt.
Ist auch alles gar nicht so einfach in einer zeit in der alle ein großes problem haben und ja wir die ganze welt im prinzip gerade versucht.
Überhaupt erst mal seinen kopf darum herum gewickelt zu bekommen was denn jetzt eigentlich gerade bei uns so vorgeht und vor allem wie man das in zahlen fassen kann wie man es in irgendeiner form quantifizieren kann.
Noch durchzuklicken und vor allem die richtigen maßnahmen daraus abzuleiten.
Ja pavel ich würde vorschlagen wir fangen einfach mal so ein bisschen mit dem feedback an was wir zur letzten sendung bekommen haben.
Da gab's ja dankenswerterweise einige beiträge in den kommentaren das teilt sich im prinzip in zwei bereiche einerseits in den ersten großen blog den wir letztes mal hatten nämlich.
Das konkrete feedback zu den vor allem den studien da fangen wir jetzt gleich mit an und dann gab's auch noch einiges feedback.
Zum thema corona tracing apps auch da gibt es einiges neues das wird auch heute wieder den zweiten block füllen
da habe ich mich ein bisschen weiter rein gelesen und werde mal berichten was ich aus meiner perspektive da gerade tut und ich kann dir sagen es geht.
Wild zur sache
ja also wir hatten ich nenne jetzt lese mal hier einen kurzen kommentar vor dem wir bekommen haben von der so ein bisschen die verwirrung glaube ich ganz gut klar macht er schrieb oder sie
die studie berichtet von einer legalität
infektion rate von null komma drei prozent pavel meldet dazu sein zweifel an und berichtet dass alle anderen studien von werten deutlich über ein prozent berichten trosten hat allerdings seit folge eins seines podcast mehrfach von einer sehr geringen sterblichkeit,
berichtet im detail erwähnt er null komma acht prozent und diverse zahlen zur c f null komma zwei bis null komma neun prozent einfach mal im transkript nach suchen etcetera noch ein video verlinkt und so weiter.
Was hier jetzt mal mache schnell vorgelesenen variante gleich deutlich wird es hier kommt eine ganze menge begriffe zusammen
und wir haben jetzt auch gerade im vorfeld der sendung auch nochmal trefflich darüber gestritten was es jetzt eigentlich wirklich die richtigen begriffe sind deswegen werden wir mal versuchen das zumindest aus unserer perspektive richtig einzuordnen weil gerade die studie scheint
hier auch nochmal zusätzlich für verwirrung gesorgt haben also die begriffe die jetzt hier im land sind sind legalität und mortalis.
Konkret halt die sogenannte.
Infektionsstation rate oder infekt,
vitality das ist die.
Und dann die fallstelle rate die c f käse verteilt.
Wir müssen wir denn das jetzt auseinander wickeln pavel um da ein verständnis zu entwickeln worüber wir eigentlich wirklich reden.
Ja also ich
habe mich in der letzten sendung bei den begrifflichkeiten an dem orientiert was halt des in seinem kot steckbrief
dazu schreibt und sie sprechen dort.
Bei der cfc vom fall verstorbenen anteil das heißt es ist im prinzip
wenn man die zahlen die im moment veröffentlicht werden die anzahl der infizierten
und die anzahl der toten die sind ja so die beiden hauptsachen die wir die wir haben wenn man die anzahl der toten durch die anzahl der infizierten jetzt teilt
bekommt man im prinzip die c d f oder den fall verstorbenen anteil wie
das beides bezeichnet wobei
da ja die noch leute später sterben daher sozusagen infektion früher nachgewiesen werden als dann die leute versterben
ändert sich der im laufe der zeit nochmal über nähert sich sozusagen an bei der berechnungsmethoden.
Ja da muss ich mal kurz einhaken nur damit das gleich von anfang an klar ist also infiziert heißt.
Es wurde nachgewiesen dass ich den virus in mich aufgenommen habe.
Fall bin ich damit aber noch nicht sondern fall bin ich wenn ich die durch diesen virus induzierte krankheit auch habe richtig.
Genau so ist zumindest es übliche.
Verständnis weil man ja immer dieses dunkelfeld hat so diese dunkelziffer an
infizierten und man das nie komplett rauskriegt kann man eigentlich die entweder nur schätzen oder
bei bestimmten ich sag mal stichproben wo man wirklich alle durchtestet.
Eigentlich ermittelt man kann sich natürlich auch hochrechnen wenn die stichprobe groß genug ist aber generell wissen wir im moment
so für deutschland die oder die legalität.
Kennen wir nicht wirklich für deutschland so das heißt.
Zuverlässig oder oder relativ einfach zu berechnen ist im moment halt der fall verstorbenen anteil zdf so.
Was das jetzt alles so verwirrend macht diese zahlen vergleiche ist dass in diesem vorab.
Print oder diese vorab informationen zur gange studie sehe aus meiner sicht die begrifflichkeiten bisschen durcheinander werfen das heißt dass sie sprechen dort von einer
c f von null komma drei sieben prozent aber beziehen sich auf die gesamtzahl aller infizierten in ihrer stichprobe.
So entnehme ich das zumindest so weil sie halt alle durchgetestet haben aber.
Weil das war ja das besondere der test war ja kein c test auf du hast jetzt gerade in dem moment wo wir dich testen den virus.
Beides wir haben beides gemacht.
Sie haben beides gemacht okay aber sie haben auch eine immunität test gemacht.
Versucht auch rauszukriegen wer die sagen wer sich wer wer hatte es denn schon mal.
Haben damit offensichtlich alle infizierten auch zu cases gemacht
so und sprechen dann deswegen von der c f an der stelle
aber um jetzt nochmal auf den kommentar von zu antworten
ja in der tat war es so dass trosten in einem ganz frühen podcast lagen wir auch deutlich unter einem prozent irgendwie bei der
bei der fallstelle rate oder bei der bei der gfa weil wir halt ganz lange keine todesfälle hatten und dann kam sie halt sehr sporadisch während die zahl der infizierten schon buch ging so,
inzwischen,
hat sich das aber angenähert also wir sind jetzt nicht von unseren null komma diese null komma zwei prozent die wir mal hatten sondern wir sind jetzt auch bei realistischen drei prozent
so gerade drei komma eins prozent das heißt diese von.
Erwähnten irgendwas prozent
waren halt einen zwischenzustand der letztlich durch die datenerhebung und dadurch dass es länger gedauert hat bis die leute verstorben sind verursacht wurde also
insofern das was ich
im letzten podcast gesagt habe kann grundsätzlich so stehenbleiben und steht auch im aktuellen steckbrief so drin also da wird nirgendwo gibt es eine cd f von unter einem prozent.
Und das war noch ein bisschen plastischer zu machen das würde quasi bedeuten dass
alle leute also von allen leuten die symptomatisch die krankheit haben so wo man sagt so du bist
krank du bist am husten oder das fieber was weiß ich du hast atembeschwerden alles mögliche bis hin eben zu du musst jetzt hier mal in die intensivmedizin das von hundert leuten denen es so geht.
Derzeit drei sterben.
So sieht's aus und es werden aber nach meinem hochrechnungen noch fünf werden am ende des tages.
Ja also die.
Naja meine im moment meine extra polierten kurven sagen die kurve die c f kurve die ich habe geht auch weiter nach oben.
Okay also mit anderen worten.
Auch in einem land mit einer relativ guten versorgung durch die krankenhäuser die noch nicht überlastet sind zumindest weitestgehend nicht überlastet sind in den allermeisten bereichen nicht überlastet sind es,
ja immer hotspots geben wo es dann überlastet da ist auch da schlägt diese krankheit zu man will das einfach nicht haben weil einfach die wahrscheinlichkeit da.
Zu sterben ist jetzt nicht gering.
Also wenn man krank wird gut hängt jetzt natürlich auch noch von alter und so weiter ab aber im durchschnitt von denen die im moment als erkrankt diagnostiziert werden.
Sind im moment bisher drei prozent gestorben von denen und es wird aber tendenziell mehr werden.
Noch als der anteil wird wird noch steigen so weil der steigt halt seit wochen.
Die analysen wäre dann jetzt mehr oder weniger betroffen ist.
Das hält halt auch alles noch an also was klar ist alter zumindest so ab sechzig oder so spielt eine relativ große rolle das ist wenig überraschend weil das immunsystem ist da halt generell schwächer aber eben.
Immer so schön sagt die ganzen conditions also wenn man irgendwelche vorerkrankungen hatte die eben das immunsystem entweder auch schon in mitleidenschaft gezogen haben krebs etcetera das ist natürlich dann auch etwas was.
Die wahrscheinlichkeit erhöht dass man dieser krankheit er liegt beziehungsweise.
Man kann halt auch einfach irgendeine genetische disposition haben von der man vielleicht derzeit noch gar nicht so genau weiß wie das ist ja also es.
Mag ja sein dass bestimmte leute gibt die einfach einfach durch irgendein gehen trick irgendein
eine resistenz oder eine geringere wahrscheinlichkeit haben überhaupt von diesem virus so stark befallen zu werden oder wo das immunsystem besser reagiert so solche geschichten nur.
Dafür ist es halt einfach derzeit noch zu früh wir haben seit vier monaten existiert diese krankheit überhaupt erst
vorher gab es die nicht und dementsprechend ist es schwierig damals auch schon was raus abzuleiten ich betone das jetzt nochmal deshalb weil wir natürlich auch da kann man dann später auch nochmal dazu in dieser ganzen bewertung mit wie schlimm ist denn das jetzt eigentlich und wie sehr ist es jetzt angemessen.
Sich hier gesamtgesellschaftlich entsprechend zu verhalten immer zu berücksichtigen ist ja also einerseits kann es sein dass man selbst nicht unbedingt in
ein bereich fällt wo man eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit hat davon zu versterben aber so ganz null ist es auf keinen fall für niemanden und außerdem
trägt man halt dazu bei dass andere leute es bekommen die dann eben eine entsprechend schlechte disposition haben also man.
Bringt leute akut in gefahr weil für manche leute ist dann einfach nur noch fifty-fifty.
Und man muss auch sagen wir haben ungefähr sagen unter sechzig genauso viele fälle wie über sechzig und auch in der altersgruppe
so von fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig sind fast genauso viele fälle wie in der altersgruppe von fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig.
Also mit fälle meister jetzt verstorbene oder leute.
Nein nein nein er erkrankte sozusagen erkrankte aber wir wissen ja auch dass auch bei so jetzt durchaus.
Jüngeren oder gesunden leuten die dann zwar nicht dran versterben die krankheit trotzdem teilweise sehr unschöne langzeitfolgen hinterlässt also es gab.
So eine diskussion um berufstand beispielsweise oder generell um taucher.
Halt eine infektion durchgemacht haben und wo unklar ist ob die jemals wieder werden tauchen können.
Im moment nachdem die diese infektion durchgemacht haben.
Die lunge so befallen wird.
Weil die lunge dermaßen geschädigt ist und es unklar ob sich das wieder komplett zurückbildet so aber im moment haben beispielsweise alle
die erkrankung durchgemacht haben und irgendwie tauchen wollen sollen sich vorher
vom arzt untersuchen lassen wie es denn um ihre lunge bestellt
also sogar bei leuten wohl die eigentlich eher eine leichte infektion durchgemacht haben hat man da trotzdem.
Lungenschäden festgestellt und das ist natürlich auch nicht so schön.
Gut wechseln wir dann mal auf die betrachtung der aktuellen zahlen diskussion jetzt haben wir seit unserer letzten aufnahme sechs tage durch es ist einiges passiert in der öffentlichen diskussion.
Es gab jetzt die ersten lockerungen seit montag.
Manche werden jetzt morgen mittwoch den dreiundzwanzigsten in kraft treten die läden etcetera es gab sehr viel diskussionen darüber ob wir den sozusagen schon soweit sind auch lockerung
wirklich zu machen und
da ging 's mal wieder viel um diese andere zahl ernten die wir ja hier auch schon ganz gut ausgerollt haben sprich.
Wie steht es denn jetzt eigentlich.
Mit der reproduktion sprich sind wir an einem punkt wo weniger leute neu angesteckt werden als gerade infiziert sind oder,
steigt es wieder und dann gab es auch da verschiedenste zahlen zu hören bis runter zu ja wir sind bei null komma sieben.
Alles super jetzt heißt es wieder eins kannst du da mal ein bisschen licht ins dunkel bringen.
Okay,
eine problematik auf die ich gestoßen bin bei der erbe rechnung und neben dem l k i macht halt auch das helmholz zentrum eigene berechnungen.
Auf eine andere art und weise kommt deswegen auch zu etwas anderen zahlen als das.
Aber eine problematik die bisher offensichtlich weder noch helmholz auf dem schirm haben sind die wochentags abhängigen schwankungen und,
wenn man halt das weiß so dass diese zahlen eigentlich im wochenrückblick aus schwanken.
Und guckt dann in die helmholz oder.
Grafiken die sie dazu veröffentlichen kann man sehr gut sieben tage peaks sehen die gleichmäßig alle sieben tage ist auch bei denen,
höher
als dazwischen und es macht sogar also man kann richtig auch eine schöne kurve sehen wo es dann runter geht und wieder in sieben tagen wieder etwas höher und wieder also wir haben sagen in beiden kann man drei schwingungen ganz deutlich
erkennen die genau im wochenrückblick muss sind so und vorher bevor wir das aufgefallen ist also als ich mir die grafiken einfach nur so angeguckt habe
ist mir das erstmal nicht aufgefallen aber mir ist natürlich aufgefallen dass die offiziellen zahlen sehr stark schwanken und ich hatte das bisher immer für einen reines artefakt der datenerhebung.
Gehalten,
aber das war mir egal weil ich wollte es herausrechnen und hab deswegen bei meinem körper fitting mir etwas gebaut was ich mal so salopp christliche logistik funktion
genannt habe die berücksichtigt dass es halt ein sonntag gibt ein heiligen sonntag und dass wir generell
einfach im wochenrückblick aus
arbeiten und funktioniert also dass unser leben unserer gesellschaftliches leben einfach im wochenrückblick auch stattfindet und das schlägt sich sowohl in der verfassung nieder als auch
vielleicht wann die leute dann zum arzt gehen weil es vielleicht sagen am wochenende lieber nicht warte ich mal noch bis montag oder so
oder die verarbeitung also es gibt auf jeden fall einen wochenrückblick aus so woher er kommt ob
das jetzt nur artefakte aus der datenerfassung sind und wann die leute sich sich melden oder,
ob es auch einen anteil gibt dass tatsächlich im laufe der woche schwankt bis
auch durchaus eine plausible theorie weil natürlich die leute.
In der woche mit anderen personen zusammen sind andere dinge tun als sie am wochenende tun das heißt
so es ist möglich dass je nachdem entweder am wochenende höher ist und in der woche niedriger oder umgekehrt.
Meine daten deuten darauf hin.
Dass der dienstag könnte auch der montag sein also montag bis mittwoch auf jeden fall der virus sich am besten verbreitet.
Am wochenende am wenigsten und das ausmaß jetzt wie stark jetzt rein rechnerisch schwankt
ist auch nochmal
deutlich größer aus den berechnungen heraus weil typischerweise für die erbe rechnung ich glaube ich schon mal gesagt teilt man die erkrankten von vier tagen durch die erkrankten der aufeinanderfolgenden vier
tage und natürlich liegen dann wenn man vier und vier nimmt.
Liegt halt meistens sagen die einen vier tage in der woche und die anderen vier tage im wochenende sodass natürlich sich entsprechend ja.
Durch diesen effekt auch nochmal stärker schwankt.
Als wenn man das einfach so flach berechnet als man glauben würde oder.
Wieso wieso nimmt man denn überhaupt vier tage also ich meine warum er nimmt man den nicht sieben.
Ja weil vier tage die generationswechsel zeit sind die angenommene also sagen wie lange es dauert bis ein infizierte den nächsten infiziert,
so daher kommt die hier und das ist jetzt auch keine super sichere zahl aber die größenordnung wird
ziemlich wahrscheinlich passen das ist es jedenfalls das,
im moment tatsächlich alle rechnen klar ich habe auch noch eine alternative berechnungsmethode wo ich die zahl der infektiösen berechne und dann immer im vier tagesabschluss gucke wie die zahl der infektiösen
zugenommen oder abgenommen hat das ergibt dann auch nochmal andere werte für
etwas höre in dem fall die auch ein bisschen weniger schwanken aber trotzdem auch wochen abhängig schwanken.
Aber müsste man nicht auf dasselbe ergebnis kommen wenn man jetzt sagt wir nehmen jetzt nicht vier sondern mit dem sieben tage also die nächsten sieben tage und die letzten sieben tage und teilen das dann müsste man dann nicht eigentlich auf dasselbe ergebnis kommen.
Nee ich wirklich nee nee dann wie gesagt erstens wird's dann geglättet so und zweitens ist es dann nicht sagt die produktionszeit
da braucht man halt das serielle intervall beziehungsweise die generationen zeit von vier tagen
mit der man da rechnet wobei das helmholz macht es halt auch nochmal ein bisschen anders die nehmen da jeweils auch zehn tages durchschnitte irgendwo
aber egal der punkt
ist jetzt bei der ganzen debatte um steigt es oder fällt es muss man halt sicher sein was es mit den wochentags.
Abhängigen schwankungen weil in den sagen offiziellen zahlen ist es so dass plus minus zwanzig prozent des ganze.
Schwankt im laufe der woche so und das bedeutet halt jetzt ganz konkret anfang april
waren wir tatsächlich unter also nach meinem berechnungen,
sind wir erstmals unter eins gekommen anfang april berichtete auch des ja aber dann ist es wieder
ein bisschen angestiegen auch in deren grafen sehen
bei mir bei meiner christlichen logistik funktion ist es aber eine ganz normale wöchentliche schwankung dieser anstieg und eine woche später ist es dann deutlich tiefer gefallen so auf null komma sieben,
vier tage später war dann wieder auf eins und vier tage später war dann wieder auf null komma sechs was wir aber jetzt sehen so die letzte schwingung das kann aber einen effekt.
Von ostern datenverarbeitung sein so die letzten tage waren halt deutlich drüber.
Da muss man jetzt noch zu sagen wir sehen ja die daten immer mit zehn bis zwölf tagen verspätung daher ist es.
So dass wenn man halt mit jetzt den zehn komma fünf tagen vom rechnet dann ist.
In der berechnung am wochenende höher aber tatsächlich haben die infektionen in der woche stattgefunden sodass muss davon nicht miteinander verwechseln aber wir haben in den offiziellen zahlen haben wir immer am wochenende
höheres und in der woche ein tieferes aber
die ansteckung funktioniert vermutlich genau umgekehrt also wenn es keine artefakte sind dann stecken sich mehr leute in der woche an als am wochenende so
ich habe heute auf twitter auch diese frage gestellt ich habe da so ein bisschen in rente,
losgelassen wo ich auch nochmal einige sachen raus erwähnen werde aber es wäre ja schön wenn
vielleicht mal sagen von offizieller seite biologen sich mal anschauen oder mal eine aussage dazu geben könnten was ist denn mit diesem,
wöchentlichen schwankungen die sind da das ist keine frage das wird keiner bestreiten aber sind es jetzt reine artefakte der datenerhebung oder waren die leute zum arzt gehen oder
ist es tatsächlich so dass sich der virus
in der woche schneller ausbreitet als am wochenende das wäre natürlich eine wichtige erkenntnis wenn dem so wäre weil das natürlich im hinblick auf maßnahmen und lockerung von maßnahmen und so eine wichtige information.
Sein kann ob sich die leute jetzt in der freizeit anstecken oder nicht die zweite sache noch wie gesagt es ist jetzt.
Zwar ja ihr reine spekulation aber was mir lange aufgefallen ist dieses vier tage serielle intervall
wenn die leute jetzt in der woche treffen sie sich mit arbeitskollegen oder mit einem bestimmten umfeld an leuten so zuhause
und fahren am wochenende aber vielleicht weg verreisen also aktuell jetzt zwar nicht aber so normalerweise das heißt
durch diese vier tage seriell ist intervall könnte es so so eine art auch noch resonanz effekt für den virus gebenden positiven dass er sagen in der woche,
steckt man seinen arbeitsumfeld und zu hause alles an oder wird angesteckt
verreist dann trägt den virus dann am wochenende woanders hin so dass dann dort wiederum die angesteckt leute dann wiederum in der nächsten woche
den den virus in ihrem arbeits-und heimfeld verbreiten können das heißt dass er das ja quasi so eine art
lokale ausbreitung und am wochenende
ausbreitung über größere entfernungen und in der woche wieder lokal müssten uns eigentlich die logen auch was zu sagen können ich habe aber tatsächlich nichts gefunden ich habe auch in der literatur gesucht
sagen zu wochenabschnitt also wochentags abhängigen.
Infektionsrisiko hatten und so und bin nicht fündig geworden also möglicherweise ist das noch gar nicht forschungsgegenstand oder war noch gar nicht forschungsgegenstand weil man,
einfach nie bisher auch so eine tagesaktuelle datenerhebung hatte wo
man sowas vielleicht überhaupt feststellen oder nachvollziehen konnte das heißt vielleicht haben wir hier lang durch die pandemien jetzt auch die chance sagen nochmal
genauer einfach zu studieren wie sich wie sich das ganze ausbreitet so abschließend jetzt auf die erde butte sagt wäre es wichtig.
Zu wissen was hat es mit diesen wöchentlichen schwankungen auf sich weil sonst reden wir immer von er ist er ist gestiegen ist gefallen oh er ist wieder gestiegen es wieder gefallen ja dann macht natürlich keinen sinn.
Und jeder verbreitet die zahlen ihm gerade am besten passen so.
Zum thema aktuell geht er wieder erwartungsgemäß runter war aber.
Also die letzten drei tage halt sehr sehr hoch also eigentlich außerhalb auch der normalen schwankungen.
Ja mein so viel vielleicht zu ärger mit tatsächlich mit dem appell
falls jemand einen epidemiologische kennt oder einer hier zuhört.
Mögen doch bitte die profis irgendwie sich äußern zu dem thema wochen tags abhängige schwankungen der infektionsrisiko.
Was ist denn jetzt das er was du jetzt gerade siehst wenn du sagst wir sind jetzt genau zwischen zwei das ist genannt segmenten zwei schwankungsbreite.
Ja also einerseits die letzten vier tage,
teilen die vier tage einfach davor also vier tage also acht tage zurück und einfach
die die summe der infizierten von tag minus acht bis minus vier und von
minus drei bis null sozusagen und das ist eine ganz ganz einfache rechnung und auch basierend einfach auf den veröffentlichten zahlen.
Muss man sagen er rechnet auch noch hatten wir glaube ich beim letzten mal aber schon erwähnt deswegen will ich da nicht so in die tiefe gehen rechnet halt auf gesäubert zahlen die altes melde datum.
Berücksichtigen und nicht wann die meldung beim eingetroffen wurde das hat aber das problem dass halt,
einige daten erst tage oder eine woche später überhaupt.
Gemeldet werden von den gesundheitsämtern das heißt es ist mit seinen sagen berechnungen zwar näher an den original.
Ereignissen dran aber.
Kann eigentlich nicht aktuell berechnen was eigentlich immer erst eine woche warten muss sagen bis alle daten eingegangen sind wenn sie auf den meldedaten arbeiten statt auf den stichtag daten so
auf den ich arbeite die zwar.
Zusätzlichen schwankungen unterworfen sind aber das sind halt dann nun mal die stichtages daten so und das sind nun mal die daten auch die wenn man vorhersagen will sind dass die daten die dann auch gemeldet werden insofern
finde ich das hilfreicher die zukünftig gemeldeten daten einschließlich ihrer.
Wie auch immer woher auch immer stammenden schwankungen vorherzusagen als
drei wochen zurückliegenden daten zu arbeiten plus das ist um das zu kompensieren sogenannten cast macht das heißt sie machen dann wiederum eine prognose wie viel.
Jetzt verspätete daten denn wahrscheinlich noch eintreffen werden was ich so ein bisschen auch für suboptimal halte weil das halt natürlich man auch nicht wissen kann so.
Ja
Man sich das eben damit erkauft mit einer geringeren aktualität und schwierigeren nachvollziehbar.
Wenn man sich das mal versucht ein bisschen plastisch vorzustellen mit diesen ganzen verzögerungen haben wir so eine so eine zeitachse mit unser bild heute
unser bild der letzten wochen und was wir so meinen was so vielleicht in den nächsten woche sich abzeichnet was passieren könnte.
Und jetzt war alle gewohnt natürlich auch so statische diagramme zu drauf zu blicken mit hier ist grade die aktuelle realität aber ich habe sowas auch schon mal irgendwo gesehen was aber jetzt,
nicht genau was da die quelle für war aber ich habe das auch mal in animierter form gesehen wo quasi auch diese ganzen
änderungen in der vergangenheit die du eben gerade beschrieben hast ja also die durch beta gemeldete dinge die man eben später erst erfahren hat und die sich ja dann sozusagen mehrfach auswirken einerseits
andere realitäten in der vergangenheit und daraus sich eben auch anders darstellende zustandsbeschreibung.
Einer etwas jüngeren vergangenheit sich alle mal ändern also sieht man so richtig wie die äste dann so immer wieder hoch und runter changieren und dadurch,
kriegt man glaube ich ein ganz gutes bild dafür wie wackelig eigentlich auch eine beliebige prognose ist.
Aber meine frage war ja jetzt was ist denn jetzt dein aktuelles r was du siehst.
Ja da sind wir gerade aktuell in der gegend von null komma sieben so also etwas unter null komma sieben wie gesagt waren aber.
Vorgestern sagen bei eins komma zwei es sind halt die wöchentlichen schwankungen und wann halt vor einer woche waren wir bei null komma fünf fünf.
Unten.
Oh das ist schon krasser unterschied ne.
Ja ja das ist natürlich schon ein krasser unterschied so und einen teil davon,
oder vielleicht alles sind halt meldet artefakte aber ich glaube nicht dass es alles melde an de facto sind und wenn es welche sind dann sind die auch beim dann ist es auch dem und dem helmholz nicht gelungen diese
rauszurechnen ja weil die haben auch peaks.
Kleinere peaks aber sie haben pieks so also irgendwo sind pieks da so also die die die schwankungen sind überall da.
Bei mir sind sie am ausgeprägtes.
Vielleicht noch noch eine sache zu den fits den ich mache zu den logistischen oder beziehungsweise komplexeren fits.
Also mit fit meist immer so anpassung kurven anpassung.
Genau eine funktion und deren parameter zu ermitteln sodass sie möglichst nah an den tatsächlichen datenpunkte entlangläuft so also sagen eine fehler minimiert funktionen eine angepasste funktion.
Das ist jetzt nicht das verfahren mit dem üblicherweise epidemiologische.
Arbeiten so die benutzen hat mir auch schon mal die sogenannten basierten modelle hatten wir auch eine.
Anfangs 'ne längere debatte zu und was du vorhin meintest mit der stabilität dieser sagen fitz also dieser gefütterten kurven
ist es so das muss man halt schon auf dem auf dem schirm haben und verstehen was da passiert deswegen schaue ich mir auch immer.
Meinem system in georg gebracht wo ich das gemacht habe habe ich dann zeit leider da kann ich so und so viel tage zurückgehen und kann mir dann sagen die vorhersagen der letzten vierzehn tage,
geben lassen und die auch überlagern alle und sehe dann halt ob die.
Wild hin und her springen oder ob die einigermaßen stabil sind und am anfang ist es so wenn noch zu wenig daten da sind ist es so dass die.
Tatsächlich die vorhersagen einfach instabil sind dass es dann mit jedem neuen daten punkt irgendwie weit nach oben weit nach unten ausschlägt aber grundsätzlich je mehr datenpunkte da sind.
Umso stabiler wird es jetzt ist noch einen zweiter punkt was diese kurven.
Diese fits auch erstmal also jeder einzelne nicht abbilden kann ist wenn sich irgendwelche parameter,
vorhergesehen ändern also wenn jetzt irgendwelche drastischen maßnahmen kommen oder irgendwann irgendwas passiert so dann
sich das aber auf dem fett kann man das dann sehen dass halt die tatsächlichen datenpunkte.
Von der vorhergesagten kurve.
Abwandern oder auswandern oder die sagen die kurven dann plötzlich eine bewegung machen sie waren was weiß ich jetzt vierzehn tage lang stabil und auf einmal geht die prognose
wieder nach oben ja dann weiß man halt auch mit den fits auch wenn die
also solche dis kontinuierlichen veränderung oder starke veränderung nicht direkt abbilden können kann man aber aus der zeit serie der fitz dann wiederum sehen sehr schön sehen
dass da irgendetwas passiert ist was eigentlich nicht hätte passieren sollen wenn sich die rahmenbedingungen nicht geändert haben so.
Ja und ansonsten bin ich halt völlig frappierend ich habe auch heute nochmal gerade auf auf twitter bilder gestellt wie krass gut diese
christlichen fits sowohl die sterblichkeitsrate zahlen auch die als auch die täglichen zahlen die schwankungen wie doch.
Überraschend gut das ganze passt so das hätte ich tatsächlich nicht erwartet so das ist.
Dass das ganze im prinzip eine sinus schwingung oder eben im wochenrückblick das ganze so gut abbildet.
Na wer weiß vielleicht kriegst du dafür ja mal noch irgendeinen preis für die entdeckung.
Springen wir mal zu den schlussfolgerungen die man jetzt im prinzip
daraus ziehen kann da will ich jetzt erstmal weniger über ist der ist die aufhebung des look downs ist gerechtfertigt oder nicht lassen wir mal offen ne ich glaube das würde jetzt,
einerseits ein bisschen zu weit führen und andererseits haben wir ja auch gerade gesehen ja okay wenn wir jetzt irgendwie
durchgehend null komma sechs haben und das seit zwei wochen dann würde ich auch sagen ja okay alles klar das ding stirbt jetzt geradeaus jetzt kann man irgendwie auch mal einen anderen umgang miteinander pflegen aber wenn das halt immer so hin und her springen zwischen ja
heute erlösung und morgen schon wieder totale panik ja die kanzlerin hat ja selber sehr schön mal diesen clip,
gesehen wo sie im fernsehen mal so diese ganze auswirkungen dargelegt hat in so einem ganz wissenschaftlichen
todesmutig fantastisch ja so ja und er liegt ja jetzt wenn es vereinzelt und so hat das auch ganz genau erklärt und wenn's bei,
komma zwei ist ja dann fünf leute einer steckt dann zwei an und vier stecken nur einen an und so weiter also
man merkte so richtig dass sie das vollständig verinnerlicht hatte so also es ist es war jetzt nicht so irgendwie ja ich habe ja mal ein zettel und lese mal vor was hier mal vorbereitet habe sondern man merkte so sind es vollständig durchdrungen was das problem ist.
Und muss natürlich jetzt mit den politischen vorlaut davon kämpfen die frage ist natürlich jetzt.
Wie gehen wir jetzt sozusagen in eine neue phase,
wir hatten es ja auch schon mehrfach angesprochen jetzt sind wir gerade noch so in dieser realität des lock-outs
so alles ist runtergefahren et cetera und ich muss sagen ich bin heute ein bisschen mit dem auto durch die gegend gekauft und ich war schon wieder überrascht wie viel verkehr auf einmal da war
also letzten tage vorher war so man kann langfahren wohin man will es mal so ein bisschen wie nachts fahren.
Und jetzt war schon wieder so stau und.
So okay also man beobachtet das heißt auch nicht am laufenden meter weiter da ist schon mehr leben in in der stadt und man merkt so richtig wie alles so ein bisschen wieder raus drängt und alles was ich irgendwie wieder so ein
in anführungsstrichen normalisieren jetzt ist das natürlich das was wir alle wollen im prinzip ja nur.
Haben wir das problem dass wir,
immer noch relativ viele infektionsstation haben also neue infektionen haben ich weiß nicht wo die rat liegt bei zweitausend pro tag derzeit so im mittel.
Ja ja also wir sind gerade also waren sagen heute bei siebzehnhundertfünfundachtzig wie gesagt die schwanken.
Halt auch im wochenrückblick muss also deswegen waren wir irgendwie vor vier tagen
waren wir noch bei dreieinhalbtausend
die dazugekommen sind jetzt sind wir erwartungsgemäß gerade wieder im tal es müsste aber eigentlich nach meiner kurve wenn wir sehen müsste es
morgen oder übermorgen also in den nächsten tagen auf jeden fall wieder hochgehen also es müsste müssten mehr infektionen gemeldet werden und
mehr tote.
Wieder also wir sind gerade sagen eher bei den neuinfektionen in im wochenthema und bei den sterblichkeitsrate zahlen auch so und deswegen werden die,
es ist das schöne mit diesen kurven dass man sich jetzt sozusagen weniger auf die zahlen vom nächsten oder übernächsten tag guckt oder wenn man weiß wenn man das erwartet dass die hochgehen und sie gehen dann hoch ist das sehr beruhigend.
Gehen wir mal jetzt von zweitausend mal aus ja so heißt
in ganz deutschland zweitausend
dann verteilt sich das eben jetzt in bestimmten bereichen anders und je nachdem wo das ist so heißt es in der region hat man dann vielleicht zwanzig bis fünfzig fälle in einer anderen region hat man vielleicht zweihundert bis dreihundert fälle.
Wenn man es auf landkreise umrechnet ich glaube wir haben was dreihundert landkreise oder sowas in in deutschland dann hat man irgendwie
hohe landkreis im schnitt eine handvoll fälle viele haben wahrscheinlich gar keine fälle und andere dann deutlich mehr aber so größenordnungsmäßigen pro tag.
Aber das worauf ich jetzt hinaus will ist ja wir müssen ein oder besolden in einem zustand kommen.
In der auch ein größerer ausbruch ja da macht ihr mal eine party da war einer infiziert auf einmal sind zwanzig dreißig leute.
Infektiös und wir merken das eben dann auch immer muss man bedenken mit verzögerung ist dauert dann einfach ein paar tage und bis man es überhaupt merkt.
Hat es sich eben schon wieder weiter verbreitet da brauchst du nur so zwei drei kroner partys haben in der folge hier im business meeting da nochmal eine kleine versammlung hier wurde nochmal geburtstag gefeiert und bis man das dann merkt.
Geht dann halt diese zahl schnell auch nochmal höher so dann hast du auf einmal die situation dass irgendein landkreis also weiß nicht ob die landkreise jetzt immer.
Der zuständigkeitsbereich eine gesundheitsbehörde ist.
Also was auch immer sozusagen jetzt die judith ist hängt es einfach schlicht davon ab wie viel kapazität hat diese gesundheitsbehörde in diesem konkret betroffenen bereich um das ganze schnell zu container,
also kontakte rauszubekommen mit wem waren sie zusammen wo er sich rumgetrieben wer könnte noch sein und so weiter alle anrufen alle waren
paar leute in quarantäne schicken maßnahmen ergreifen die leute durchtesten schauen dass man der sache schnell wieder her wird und
das dann sozusagen lokal runtergedrückt bekommen bevor die leute anfangen urlaub zu fahren und noch so ein produziert und dann geht der ganze scheiß wieder von vorne los das ist die situation die wir haben wollen,
und jetzt hast du ja heute in deinem von dir schon erwähnten rand im prinzip bemerkt,
dass das problem ist dass wir eigentlich gar nicht wissen von diesen zweitausenddrei leuten die sich jetzt täglich anstecken.
Wo stecken sie sich an bei wem stecken sich an wie stecken sich an an welchen tagen stecken wir wir haben's ja schon angesprochen diese schwankungen ja ist es arbeit ist es ist es wochenende.
Wir wissen es.
Einkaufen ist das ö p n v.
Genau und wenn wir das nicht wissen haben wir natürlich einen riesen nachteil.
In der verfolgung dieser fälle und das schlimmste was uns halt jetzt passieren kann ist und das hat auch frau merkel schön gesagt so wer ja jammerschade hat sie gesagt.
Super wort es wäre ja jammerschade wenn wir jetzt irgendwie diesen schönen schönen look down indem wir alle so kreativ geworden sind und uns neu kennengelernt haben jetzt auflösen würden.
Und dann würde dieser ganze scheiß wieder von vorne los gehen weil wir uns auf einmal in der situation finden,
wieder fünftausend neue fälle in deutschland quer verteilt über die ganze republik
keiner weiß wo es herkommt keiner weiß wer da gerade was irgendwohin trägt und wir müssen im prinzip wieder mit einem generellen lok down arbeiten anstatt mit so einem lokalen doktor weil auch diese
soll ich sagen dieser dieser ausbruchs voll den ich jetzt gerade mal so hypothetischen raum geworfen habe.
Sagen wir mal da ist jetzt ein so eine art lokale messe gewesen.
Hannover messe oder so aber da hängen also da vierhundert leute und die machen also ihr business meeting und da hat sich das dann verbreitet und man merkt das dann irgendwie vier fünf tage später was macht man dann,
wenn man weiß dass,
aha okay der war infektiös mit einer sohn so hohen wahrscheinlichkeit weil er auf diesem event die wahrscheinlichkeit dass alle leute die auf diesem event waren irgendwie auch was mitgetragen haben ist relativ hoch.
Was macht man an dann schickt man die halt alle kollektiv in den look da da ruft man da an und sagt ihr seid jetzt einfach mal alle und eure familien und sorry und eure firmen und ich weiß und es scheiße und hier ist die telefonnummer
könnt ihr euch so aber nur dieser bereich soll davon betroffen sein damit der rest deutschlands davon nicht betroffen ist.
So hat südkorea im übrigen das ganze in den griff gekriegt die sind halt die hatten halt dann auch,
richtig ermittler teams die den clustern nachgegangen sind und die haben dann mal eben zweihunderttausend leute von dieser christlichen sekte unter quarantäne gestellt
präventiv oder von einer anderen veranstaltung da waren irgendwie zwanzigtausend leute auf einem konzert wo dann fälle bekannt geworden sind das ist halt jeder der auf dem konzert war war dann aufgefordert
so sich in quarantäne zu begeben so so lief das da.
Ab aber dazu sind wir offenbar derzeit nicht gut in der lage jedenfalls.
Was die lockerung jetzt das lockt down angeht vielleicht noch noch noch eine sache die sich ein nachgang in der debatte.
Weil man kann auch gucken oder versuchen nachzuvollziehen was haben denn diese einzelnen drei maßnahmen.
Wünsche.
Eigentlich jetzt gebracht haben die irgendwie hatten die wirkungen und das einzige was man aus den erbe rechnungen jetzt sagen kann war das.
Also erstens sieht es nicht so aus,
jetzt meinen berechnungen finden sich jetzt keine konkreten zeitpunkte wo sich jetzt dinge plötzlich,
geändert haben faktisch hat ihre sogar schon angefangen zu fallen
bevor überhaupt nur die ersten maßnahmen begonnen wurden am neunten dritten da war nämlich schon panik also am neunten dritten war schon klopapier ausverkauft
und masken waren ausverkauft so das heißt die leute hatten bereits vorher schon reagiert.
Irgendwie als dann die schulschließungen kam zu dem zeitpunkt war mir so knapp,
über eins nach meinen berechnungen nach berechnungen war mir noch bei eins komma sechs zu dem zeitpunkt der schulschließungen aber,
es ging dann halt ständig runter und auch beim in dem kurve kann man jetzt nicht irgendwie,
einzelne maßnahmen.
Ausfindig machen aber wo wiederum meine kurve mit der vom übereinstimmt ist dass das letzte maßnahmenbündel sagen der der lok down so der am zweiundzwanzigsten.
Drittens dreiundzwanzigsten dritten montag offiziell begonnen hat.
Da hat sich nichts mehr geändert da war er schon seit einer woche unter eins das heißt diese dinger haben jetzt zumindest.
Ihn nicht gedrückt jetzt kann man sagen gut wenn sie jetzt nicht eingeführt worden wäre wäre er dann vielleicht wieder angestiegen er.
Wahrscheinlich nicht so das heißt man könnte jetzt sagen aus den zahlen heraus bei aller problematik dass mit sagen den maßnahmen vom dreiundzwanzigsten dritten scheint jetzt nicht so kriegsentscheidend
gewesen zu sein eher schon davor die schulschließungen beziehungsweise davor dann das allgemeine bewusstsein das ist gefährlich
wird so dass das hat offensichtlich schon 'ne ganze menge gebracht aber so mein gefühl.
Was jetzt die lockerungen betrifft gerade die sind weitgehend unlogisch und unwissenschaftlich so also,
ich sehe in den zahlen keinerlei grundlage warum bestimmte maßnahmen gelockert werden oder nicht und um nochmal drauf zurückzukommen,
in welchen situationen stecken sich eigentlich die zwei dreitausend leute oder muss genauer sagen vor vierzehn tagen oder vor zehn bis vierzehn tagen.
Wo haben sich die leute eigentlich angesteckt was sind die löcher ich meine wir haben nun mal den den look down und was sind die gefährlichen
situation wenn wir das wüssten könnten wir halt
einfach zielgerichteter bei den maßnahmen entweder in bestimmten bereichen vielleicht sogar verschärfen in anderen bereichen vielleicht lockern aber leider
bestes berichtswesen in deutschland
eine katastrophe so eigentlich ist das die zuständigkeit der gesundheitsämtern das ganze ist eine meldepflichtig krankheit und
eigentlich müssten die alle in der lage sein super daten zu erheben ich meine die sind auf der einen seite sind die daten ganz gut leider nicht nicht öffentlich
so zugänglich aber da stehen halt ganz viele sachen drin wie alter und geschlecht und symptome und also das ist schon die meldungen an sich
sind schon gar nicht so schlecht aber.
Sie sind halt nicht aktuell das ist das hauptproblem wenn wir jetzt gerade steuern wollen und der punkt ist einfach
so wie das meldeweg im moment funktioniert,
können wir nicht steuern ja die krankheit hat eben diese generationen zeit von vier tagen und wir können im prinzip erst drei wochen später wirklich darauf reagieren vielleicht zwei
das ist einfach ein unerträglicher zustand und eigentlich könnte man diese zeit auf sechs tage verkürzen meiner meinung nach wenn man
das nur vernünftig organisieren würde aber so in den letzten
sechs wochen ist da einfach zu wenig passiert okay ein problem ist dass die gesundheitsämtern halt in den letzten jahren
auch personell und finanziell und so ziemlich runtergewirtschaftet wurden das heißt das ist sozusagen ein problem und.
Das andere problem ist dass so wie das,
offenbar organisiert ist ist es ganz schwierig irgendwie schnell was zu ändern beziehungsweise die einzelnen enter können nicht von sich aus irgendwas tun sondern es muss jetzt von oben kommen und von oben
es war wohl es ist wohl einiges passiert man versucht jetzt sagen schon zusätzliches personal zu rekrutieren und das
auszubauen und so kapazitäten mäßig aber ich muss sagen wir sind tag einen schönen spät
dran ich meine wir wissen das jetzt nicht erst seit gestern so und ich vermisse einfach und das war der hintergrund meines rennens ich vermisse einfach dass also dieser look down ist vorhin halt einfach mal jetzt sechs wochen zeit verschwendet.
Und offensichtlich ist auch vielen leuten nicht klar wie wichtig das ist gute und genaue,
daten zu haben so für die ist es vielleicht irgendwie keine ahnung statistik oder so und ja damit man hinterher weiß aber nein nein das ist halt
irgendwie
im moment wahrscheinlich genauso wichtig wie irgendwelche heilmittel zu finden oder oder andere dinge zu tun weil es nämlich tatsächlich einfach menschen leben effektiv
retten kann im moment in großen maßstab und auch ökonomisch bedeutsam ist so und da muss ich sagen
auch immer zur app kommen wir noch später aber ich finde
bevor irgendwie jetzt die bundesregierung oder wer auch immer anfängt über apps zu formulieren hätten sie einfach mal ihre hausaufgaben machen können und die datenverarbeitung der gesundheitsämtern mal auf,
und vordermann bringen weil die sind dafür zuständig das sind vorhandene strukturen so da sind zigtausend leute die.
Eigentlich eingesetzt werden können um dinge zu tun aber
es geht halt einfach nicht schnell genug und man hat das gefühl so da haben einige leute noch nicht begriffen was hier eigentlich gerade abgeht und.
Mein anderes staaten zeigen auch dass das dass das deutlich besser geht und deutlich schneller.
Wir hatten ja wenn ich da mal kurz dazwischen greifen darf ganz unsere allerersten sendung ja wo wir sache auch noch etwas jovialer genommen haben weil wir auch noch nicht so richtig wussten was für ein nest wie eigentlich sitzen.
Hat mir auch gesagt na ja hier die zahlen kommen spät rein ja wahrscheinlich weil weil die alle mit faxe per fax übertragen werden und hatten ja eine woche später dann tatsächlich diese meldung ja war so war fast so und faxnummer waren überlagert und ich weiß dass mittlerweile ist das alles abgeschaltet
so hat irgendwie das eine woche lang irgendwie ertragen und danach auch so ein digitales meldeweg in irgendeiner form durchgesetzt wie das konkret funktioniert keine ahnung wovon wir ganz weit entfernt sind was jetzt hier an dieser stelle auch
wohl erforderlich wäre wenn du sagst könnte man auf sechs tage runterbringen würde mir auch mal interessieren was du da vorschlagen würdest es fehlt auf jeden fall ein kohärenten
allgemeines gleichförmig funktionierendes einheitliches system.
Ja also er hat konkret dazu.
Was ich glaube was das optimum wäre natürlich kann man erst überhaupt.
Im moment wissen wenn jemand symptome hat was im schnitt nach fünf tagen,
der fall ist so das heißt als erstes müsste man jedem,
die schnelle möglichkeit eröffnen sobald er irgendwie einen kratzen im hals verspürt sollte es möglich sein
irgendwo hinzufahren und innerhalb von einer stunde einen test zu bekommen,
wenn der wenn der test im im labor ist dann dauert es ein paar stunden bis das testergebnis da ist dass man halt vorbereitet werden aber auch diese kette könnte man beschleunigen so dass das halt stündlich sagen jemand.
Die tests einsammelt und ins labor bringt so und damit nach sechs bis acht stunden also ich spüre kratzen im hals mache.
Eine stunde später einen test und hab sechs bis acht stunden später das ergebnis ja vier stunden später wie auch auch immer so.
Wenn dieses ergebnis da ist kann eigentlich das labor dieses ergebnis schon mal direkt.
Melden ohne jegliche verzögerung so das heißt wir sind bei sechs tagen.
Vielleicht noch nicht mit allen meter daten vielleicht noch nicht mit allen ist was weiß ich geschlecht und tralala und persönliche informationen und so weiter aber die kann man ja auch später noch holen.
Ich meine es ist ja nicht so schwierig dass jeder der sich testen lässt muss halt dann irgendwie seinen geburtsdatum angeben und welche symptome er gerade hat und also der kann ja das formular einfach da gleich vor ort.
Fühlen und das kann man ja gleich irgendwie der der der probe mitgeben man kann es ja sogar als q code mit drauf drucken
und dann können die das einfach mit einem handy abscannen und übertragen ja also so.
Technisch sollte es also sechs tage meiner meinung nach ist wenn jemand.
Tome hat sollte es möglich sein dass der am nächsten tag diagnostiziert und gemeldet ist so punkt alles andere ist dreck.
Ich hatte ja hier vor ein paar wochen auch mal den fall mit rudi der bei mir in der friedhof mit dabei ist der offensichtlich,
weiß das glaube ich bis heute noch nicht also weiß bis heute nicht offiziell aber es sich relativ sicher ja also auch den virus eingefangen hat und seine vergeblichen versuche über tage und wochen.
Irgendwie irgendwo durchzudringen und zu sagen hier ich hab's wahrscheinlich ich würde mich gerne testen so und da
kam dann halt auch am anfang von vielen so na ja wieso halte ich doch einfach in der quarantäne und ist gut dann bist du erstmal aus dem feld ja das stimmt aber dann haben wir diese zahlen nicht und das ist eben das womit wir arbeiten müssen jetzt
und zweiter fall eine nachbarin die auch.
Auch den virus sich eingefangen hatte auch ein relativ harten krankheitsverlauf hatte aber geradezu.
Den hausarzt an mitteln musste so der meinte so ja nee das ist ja jetzt hier auch
grippewelle und so weiter das kann jetzt alles mögliche sein und bitte also mehrere male insistieren musste so nach dem motto erste mit diesem argument mit hier groß verlust ja ich schlüpfe
ich schnüffel eine essigflaschen und es riecht wie wasser ja erzähl mir nicht dass das
nicht dieser virus ist so erst dann war es möglich über diesen hausarzt ein entsprechenden test durchzuführen.
Und das ist einfach ein zustand der der der geht so nicht wenn wir das in irgendeiner form containern wollt.
Ich glaube es ist besser geworden aber es ist trotzdem noch luft nach oben
so definitiv luft nach oben einfach auch muss man halt dafür sorgen dass auch älter und alles am wochenende besetzt sind und das
halt vierundzwanzig sieben tests bis hin zu meine was andere länder haben teilweise auch halt das taxi da rufst du dann an und dann kommt halt jemand bei dir vorbei und nimmt 'ne probe damit du nicht aus dem haus
musst so warum haben wir nicht irgendwie statt ich weiß nicht zehn kokain taxi ist einfach zehn korona taxis.
In berlin ja ich meine.
Ja
Ja auf jeden fall dieser mein bisher muss ich sagen war ich ja.
Relativ zufrieden immer mit dem wie das eigentlich bisher
gehandhabt wurde so auch mit den look down und den maßnahmen und so vor dem hintergrund dass man nichts wusste und lieber auf nummer sicher gehen aber ich habe jetzt das gefühl
die zeit wurde verschwendet und verschlafen die wir jetzt gewonnen haben weil.
Der punkt ist dass uns das ganze entglitten ist weil die gesundheitsämtern ihrer aufgabe nicht gewachsen waren mein gut.
Kann man verstehen gab es seit hundert jahren keine panik die mehr ok auch in den meinen letzten zehn jahren war es zwar immer thema aber gut was soll's wir haben muss man sagen wir haben das jetzt alle nicht,
jetzt als wenn man nicht wahrscheinlich nicht beruflich damit befasst war oder so hat man das irgendwie als doch sehr abstrakte und entfernte gefahr wahrgenommen aber
so nichtsdestotrotz ich meine die gesundheitsämtern oder ist also es gab genug warnungen aber ok so aber jetzt ist es halt gekommen und eigentlich.
Wäre es aufgabe der gesundheitsämtern wie mit allen anderen meldepflichtig krankheiten dem sofort nachzugehen und.
Die leute unter quarantäne zu stellen und deren kontakte nachzuverfolgen und zu sorgen dass das ganze eingedämmt wird gelingt bei anderen viel ansteckenden krankheiten gelingt es wunderbar gut weil auch,
natürlich leute immunität haben und die ausbrüche nicht so rapide sind was er sich bei masern oder rütteln oder so aber windpocken.
Aber so bei korona hat's halt einfach nicht funktioniert weil es einfach zu viel und zu plötzlich und zu neu und ja so.
Aber es ist sagen den gesundheitsämtern entglitten so jetzt müsste man eigentlich erwarten dass im hinblick auf.
Wir müssen irgendwann mal aufheben die gesundheitsämtern und die prozesse so also gesundheitsämtern so ausgestattet und die prozesse so verbessert werden dass uns das nicht ein zweites mal entgleitet.
Dass es möglich wird nachzuverfolgen aber
wenn ich allein nur sehe wie schleppend das mit den blöden zahlen was ja ja eigentlich.
Nicht so das große problem sein dürfte und selbst da gibt es es gibt einfach zu wenig fortschritte und ich befürchte einfach dass,
die maßnahmen zur stärkung der gesundheitsämtern bei weitem nicht ausreichend waren und ich meine da passiert jetzt wahrscheinlich einiges
aber spät spät.
So und ob es ausreichen wird ja sehen hoffentlich nicht.
Jetzt ist ein bisschen die frage.
Was würden wir denn so vorschlagen ich meine jetzt sind wir beide so ein bisschen bei ist weil wir so aus der ganzen computer automatisierungsgrad tätig kommen ne also
programmierer denkt bei jedem problem immer als erstes dran okay wie kann man das jetzt irgendwie generalisieren wie kann man das stream leiden wie kann man das irgendwie ein protokoll fassen das
unser erster gedanke ignoriert auch nicht selten so ein bisschen die humanoiden realitäten dieser ein bisschen dazwischen stehen beziehungsweise in so einem behördlichen kontext natürlich dann auch eben die bürokratischen hürden nichtsdestotrotz ist es ja geboten hier irgendwas zum laufen zu bekommen
und wie schwierig das ist das selbe auch gleich nochmal wenn man über die dressing app reden nur mir willst nicht so richtig im kopf dass das so schwierig ist.
Er ist es eigentlich auch nicht also ein gutes beispiel jetzt wo es einigermaßen geklappt hat auch ein bisschen suboptimal aber ist halt dies diva zentralregister
die ist.
Eigentlich ein lobbyisten-verband intensiv mediziner lobbyverband so und die haben dann mal kurzerhand.
Aus eigeninitiative
so wie ich das verstanden habe sowas wie einen zentralregister angelegt also eine webseite gemacht wo kliniken accounts kriegen konnten sich sich klicken konnten
und dann halt dort die zahl der angebotenen und freien intensivbetten melden konnten so
und das hat dann sehr schnell auch um sich gegriffen so da haben dann auch
großteil so über tausend kliniken glaube bis zu tausenddreihundertsechsundzwanzig.
Intensivbetten anbieten die hatten sich da auch fast alle registriert allerdings
das regelmäßige tägliche melden hat dann erstmal nicht gut funktioniert so als dann nämlich die das zentralregister umgestellt haben dass sie nur die daten die in den letzten sechsunddreißig stunden oder also vortag
aktueller tag berücksichtigt haben schrumpfte plötzlich die zahl extreme plötzlich nur noch sechs siebenhundert kliniken mittlerweile
gibt es eine meldepflichten hat die glaub ich bundesregierung sagt krankenhäuser ihr müsst an steve zentral
register milden und seitdem so sind jetzt fünfundneunzig prozent melden jetzt gerade aber auch nur intensivbetten
so normale betten zahlen werden.
Offenbar nicht mit gemeldet also wenn jemand nur wenn jemand auf der intensivstation ist aber wenn man die ist die zentralregister ist ein ganz gutes beispiel dafür dass man in relativ kurzer zeit die haben das in wenigen wochen
so aus der taufe gehoben hätte man auch in anderen bereichen machen können also
dass ich hätte auch eine eigene website bauen können in zwei wochen wo dann die gesundheitsämtern direkt melden aber hat man natürlich nicht gemacht weil es gibt ja schon bereits ein system wo gemeldet werden kann deswegen warum irgendwas anderes noch bauen nur.
Problem mit den prozessen wohl ich habe dann gehört okay warum melden die gesundheitsämtern zum teil nicht direkt weil ihnen dann daten fehlen also wenn es kein,
geburtsdatum oder so ist können sie es wohl nicht abschicken oder schicken sie es nicht ab oder warten dann halt bis halt sie auch alle felder irgendwie dann.
Weil sie es nicht abspeichern können und nicht nachträglich noch anreichern können.
Das ist.
So ein bisschen dort das problem aber grundsätzlich ja sagen website bauen daten erfassen
auch eine eine app dafür also es ist alles nichts es ist alles nicht schwierig ist alles nichts was man nicht innerhalb von ein paar wochen
lösen könnte sagen wir in einem monat auch in einem
halbwegs qualitativ hochwertigen zustand also jetzt sicherlich nicht perfekt mit mit allen bells and visuals aber funktional und nicht völlig unsicher und ja.
Es gab ja diesen hacker von der auch relativ früh gestartet wurde ich bin mir grade nicht mehr so ganz so sicher ich glaube es war ohnehin was geplant gewesen war daher hatte man so,
gewissen vorsprung hat das dann quasi thematisch umgewidmet
da kam er dann auch relativ schnell lösungen teilweise auch für die tracing apps teilweise es gab dann auch glaube ich so ein super set so ein interface für dieses die zentralregister etcetera also da ist auch sehr schnell was
passiert und wir alle wissen es ist eigentlich relativ easy auch ein komplexes system.
Zu achtzig prozent schnell fertig zu bekommen.
Ja klar dann hast du am schluss hast nochmal so ein paar cases und bist dann wirklich fertig ist und lalala passt ein paar bucks und performance probleme und so weiter und der datenschutz und das muss ja auch alles nochmal abgenommen werden und so
ganz klar ne und die letzten zwanzig prozent sind immer achtzig prozent der arbeit wissen wir alle aber man kommt halt auch schnell irgendwohin und man kann vor allem dann auch durch so einen sage ich mal das böse wort und agilen prozess schnell auch sehen,
okay ist das etwas was uns hilft ist das ist das der richtige weg ist ist das das wo man hinarbeiten sollte
oder ist es eher was was man dann wieder wegschmeißt weil man merkt so ja ist nicht so ganz das was wir brauchen dann starten wir halt nochmal ein parallelen prozess diese ganze parallelität sowie irgendwie jetzt bild gates anfängt sieben fabriken parallel zu finanzieren die aufgebaut werden sollen um einen
mögliches
impfmittel zu produzieren die alle auf ganz anderen unterschiedlichen medizinischen viro logischen prinzipien basieren.
Also nicht medizinisch aber fahr mal pharmakologische keine ahnung wie man das jetzt nennt also
unterschiedliche impfstoffe brauchen einfach unterschiedliche produktionsmethode brauchen unterschiedliche fabriken und damit jetzt gar nicht erst gewartet baut halt einfach mal sieben so und eine davon werden wir brauchen die anderen sechs schmeiß mal dann weg oder können wir vielleicht für irgendwas anderes noch gebrauchen,
ist jetzt egal verlieren derzeit sowieso mehr geld als das halt das kostet und das das ist auch so eine denkweise die,
ja ich will jetzt nicht wieder in so eine digital klage ausbrechen weil es hat mir hier auch schon uns wiederholt sich ein bisschen so ne aber da fehlt einfach auch ein bisschen der mut zum ausprobieren.
Ich meine diese vorgehensweise ist auch zufällig dieselbe wenn du in china eine hardware entwicklung in auftrag gibst,
was er sich irgendein gerät entwickeln lassen willst dann setzen die üblicherweise drei teams dran die unabhängig voneinander das machen und
das team was als erstes fertig ist dessen lösung wird dann halt genommen so.
Ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht die optimale variante aber so das hilft natürlich auf jeden fall schnell zum ziel zu kommen und wenn es funktioniert.
Ja nicht unbedingt auch meine,
lieblingsmethode dinge zu entwickeln weil es ist natürlich dann am ende dreimal so teuer aber vielleicht dann doch nicht weil wenn dein team nämlich in eine sackgasse läuft so hast du halt ein anderes team des vielleicht relativ schnell ans ans ziel kommt so
deswegen ja macht in so einer situation total total sinn ja man hätte vielleicht einfach mal keine ahnung zehn melde systeme ausschreiben sollen wettbewerb hier
wir wollen in drei wochen ein system haben dass das und das macht und dann finanziert man halt zehn
parallele entwicklungen und guckt wer kommt mit dem besten system um die ecke.
Ja man muss ja nicht bis zum ende finanzieller keiner sagen okay die ersten zehn entwicklung finanzieren wir jetzt für zwei wochen.
Und danach finanzieren wir davon drei und nach vier wochen gucken wir mal wer gewinnt so
was für ein ansporn und niemand muss quasi für lau arbeiten,
auch ein interessanter faktor ja dann hat man halt nicht gewonnen aber jetzt ist auch nicht so ein pitch wo man irgendwie als eine ganze arbeitszeit reinstecken muss selbstständigen gestalter problematik ne und dann hast du
am ende überhaupt nichts davon gehabt und das ist dann einfach für die gesamte
erstmal nicht so sehr viel teurer kann man einfach mit rein kalkulieren und vor allem was du eben nur so ansatzweise macht noch angesprochen hast was ja auch noch so ein faktor ist wenn du nur ein team hast.
Was dann so voranschreitet und du stellst dann irgendwann feste sackgasse dann verlierst du nochmal zeit.
Weil das ein ganz natürlicher verständlicher prozess dieses team sich dann dagegen wehrt und alle möglichen gründe erfinden wird warum ihr weg doch vielleicht nicht schlecht ist so und damit findest du nochmal zeit und.
Wir haben hier eine menge zu verlieren gerade aber vor allem keine zeit.
So wir können dann ans sagen zum zum ende von meinem com denke ich also was im moment absolut inakzeptabel ist kann man feststellen dass sie
irgendwie zum teil eine woche später melden als sie könnten und das ist einfach unerträglich und es muss einfach aufhören und das das problem ist
das halt ohne gute daten die aufhebung der maßnahmen gerade zum glücksspiel mit der gesundheit der bevölkerung ausartet.
Und da erwarte ich einfach dass die regierenden in bund und ländern einfach ihre hausaufgaben machen und endlich für bessere daten sorgen und zwar schleunigst.
Und bei den epidemiologische würde ich mich freuen wie gesagt wenn irgendjemand mal was
von berufenen seite zu den wöchentlichen schwankungen
sagen könnte und zu den situationen wo denn eigentlich jetzt ansteckungen passieren so das müsste doch eigentlich möglich sein mit den ressourcen die wir haben zumindest
größenordnungen anzugeben zumindest zu sagen okay.
Berufstätige die nicht im home-office arbeiten wurden irgendwie dreimal mehr infiziert als leute die zu hause sitzen oder mitarbeiter im supermarkt.
Sind halt in viel mehr betroffen als so mitarbeiter anderswo.
Lieferdienste.
Ja also auf jeden fall bin ich halt mittlerweile etwas ja ungeduldig und erbost darüber dass wir immer noch
im dunkeln tappen da läuft uns jetzt gerade einfach die zeit weg wie gesagt ein paar maßnahmen.
Kann man wahrscheinlich aufgrund der zahlen aufheben insbesondere halt die vom dreiundzwanzigsten dritten aber.
Was jetzt so mit läden angeht beispielsweise da gab's jetzt irgendwie so was war das.
Quadratmeter regelung.
Quadratmeter grenze so die mir halt überhaupt nicht einleuchtet weil
er sagen müsst okay wenn der laden größer ist dann ist auch mehr platz können sich die leute besser ausweichen eigentlich
müsste man halt weiterhin dafür sorgen wenn die läden auch offen sind dass man halt einfach vorschreibt
wie viele leute pro quadratmeter denn überhaupt in den laden.
Das ist auch das ist auch getan worden ist und zwanzig quadratmeter pro teilnehmer also pro besucher.
Okay okay das macht dann sinn aber warum man dann warum dann die begrenzung auf achthundert quadratmeter des erschließt sich mir nicht hast du deine ahnung.
Kann ja auch nur rumzudeuteln ist auch ein bisschen unklar weil 's hat man gerade dieses problem mit shopping mals ja so,
sind das dann die einzelnen läden die da sozusagen an so eine künstliche straße angeschlossen sind wo nochmal dach drüber ist sind das jetzt einzelnen läden oder nicht in berlin ist jetzt glaube ich die regelung ab morgen so dass eben shopping mals quasi auch als einzelner läden.
Gewertet werden ob das dann eine kluge idee ist oder nicht aber dann steht da kaufhof und sagt so.
Whatsapp friends so also ich meine wir können auch leute mit elektronischen zähler an den eingang stellen und sagen es sind jetzt nur so und so viele leute hier drin dann haben wir zwar nicht
tausend leute im haus sondern vielleicht nur hundert
aber dann gibt's halt zumindest mal keine warteschlangen an der kasse was ja mal ganz angenehm ist und natürlich verkaufen wir auch nicht so viel aber die leute merken auch dass es,
das ist ein anderes regime da ist also ich ich kann es auch nur begrenzt nachvollziehen vielleicht gibt's da irgendwo noch eine geheime logik will es jetzt gar nicht verteufeln aber zumindest wir wissen es nicht es gibt keine
darlegung was der konkrete grund dafür ist und das ist glaube ich das problem was wir ja eigentlich ansprechen wollen.
Gut pavel dann lass uns mal noch kurz auf die internationale situation kommt aber jetzt sehr viel ins detail gegangen sind vielleicht einen kleinen.
Überblick was dir noch aufgefallen ist was berichtenswertes.
Ja sich kann noch was zu
italien sagen also italien beim letzten mal glaube ich schon ist und bleibt spannend weil
es dort aussieht als würde zum einen die zahl der toten
weiter ansteigen oder nicht so schnell abnehmen es war so wie
sie ist eigentlich sollte er sollte sich die abnahme verlangsamt so und ja es läuft jetzt in der spitze irgendwo auf dreißigtausend
raus im übrigen hat italien auch diesen christlichen rhythmus ein bisschen weniger aber somit siebzehn prozent bei den toten und achtzehneinhalb bei den infizierten
so plus minus jeweils und auch die zahl der infizierten wandert weiter nach nach oben
aus so also es geht in italien
nicht so schnell zurück wie es eigentlich sollte kann man mal vielleicht dabei belassen du hattest glaube ich auch irgendjemand hatte irgendwie auch noch noch einen möglichen grund dafür genannt.
Ja also es gab in den kommentaren die anregungen das vielleicht so zu sehen dass wir ja es in italien auch mit einer erheblichen überlastung.
Des gesundheitssystems zu tun hatten also kommt noch mehrere faktoren rein also norditalien ist ja auch besonders
betroffen von luftverschmutzung einer der krassesten gebiete in europa wo luftverschmutzung durch die industrielle aktiv
extrem hoch ist aber der hinweis war eher naja wenn das gesundheitssystem so extrem überlastet war ne also dass viele halt unter umständen dann auch erst gar nicht in die.
Krankenhäuser gefahren sind und dementsprechend auch nicht als infiziert gemeldet wurden und da sich natürlich dann
auch tote ergeben und jetzt wo sich sozusagen die situation in den krankenhäusern etwas bessert
es dann wiederum einen zweiten rasch gibt der dahinterher geht auch ein bisschen spekulativ das wird man glaube ich auch alles erst am ende wirklich sagen können.
Also klingt jedenfalls nicht nicht unklar sibel so weil eigentlich lockerungen
dass es auswirkungen irgendwelcher lockerungen sein könnten dafür ist es noch zu früh eventuell höchstens dann ausnahmen dass die leute wie auch hier anfangen dann doch vielleicht.
Unvorsichtiger zu werden das könnte es natürlich auch sein aber wollen wir nicht hoffen gut also italien.
Sieht jetzt nicht unbedingt katastrophal aus aber sowohl die zahl der infizierten als auf die zahl der toten wandert halt weiter nach oben aus als es.
Eigentlich idealerweise hätte laufen können oder sollen.
Zwei länder die wo ich finde dass die extrem unter berichtet sind einerseits frankreich
viel über spanien italien geredet aber auch frankreich hat es ja doch extrem hart getroffen und die zahlen sowie sie sich jetzt in der johns hopkins statistik abzeichnet ja auch irgendwie.
Sehr merkwürdig also extremer
anstieg angemeldeten funktionen kann natürlich auch wieder mit tests zu tun haben aber die zahl der toten ist auch extrem hoch frankreich ist auf jeden fall auch noch nicht aus dem gröbsten raus habe ich so den eindruck.
Und vollkommen unterbelichtet ist die situation in belgien jetzt ist da.
Absolute zahl nicht so hoch.
Aber es ist auch ein kleines land und ich habe das jetzt leider nicht gefunden auf world in data gab es zumindest ich habe es jetzt nicht vor der sendung nicht wiedergefunden diese grafik aber es gab mal eine aufschlüsselung der toten zahlen,
in relation zur bevölkerung.
Es ist ja eher so ein bisschen absurd also man schaut immer so auf die absoluten zahlen sondern die usa haben jetzt so viele zahlen naja okay u s a ist auch ein riesen land mit dreihundert millionen einwohnern aber dem kleinen belgien lag,
die zahl von toten pro hunderttausend.
Viel viel höher als in allen anderen ländern also belgien ist eigentlich das am härtesten betroffene land derzeit aus der perspektive gesehen.
Sie haben absolut fünfunddreißigtausend infektionen gerade.
Ja und für so einen kleines land ist das nicht schön und gut es sieht zwar auch da aus als würde die kurve ein bisschen abflachen aber gleichzeitig wandert sie auch nach.
Oben aus dass die letzten datenpunkte das kann auch irgendwie austern osterfest sein oder so aber absolut ja.
Gebe ich dir recht belgien ist ziemlich krass gerade was sagen denn noch so hotspots.
In den wurst ganz krass auch abgeht gerade ist in vielen der kleinen golfstaaten also.
Verein ist ist ziemlich heftig so.
Geht ziemlich ab zwar alles erstmal von niedrigen.
Level aus aber ja also generell am am golf schien es jedenfalls ganz gut abzugehen saudi-arabien ist auch ziemlich am.
Noch am anziehende ist auch noch keine keine keine verlangsamung zu sehen interessant
vielleicht noch die situation in schweden sollte man eigentlich nochmal vielleicht kurz ansprechen die man schweden ist ja so ein bisschen ein sonderweg gegangen ohne lok down so größeren und.
Steht von den zahlen her jetzt eigentlich auch gar nicht so schlecht da wie man erwarten könnte also ein bisschen schlechter als norwegen aber unwesentlich wo,
norwegen noch eines der besten gesundheitssystem hat gut jetzt sagen viele leute ja gut schweden wird irgendwie auch nicht richtig gemeldet und die zahlen werden angezweifelt und so aber es gab auch
ja doch böse anwürfe von anderen skandinavischen ländern gegenüber schweden.
Dass sie das zu lachs handhaben aber bisher scheinen die noch.
So ganz gut damit klar zu kommen so also die sind jetzt auch die scheinen auch so die.
Kurve ja gekriegt zu haben also auch da sind gegen die infizierten zahlen mittlerweile zurück ja ja.
Ja gut aber ich sehe tausendachthundert tote ungefähr also wenn du bei zehn millionen einwohnern.
Muss man sagen das heißt das wäre auf deutschland bezogen werden dass irgendwie siebzehntausend tote.
Und wir sind gerade mal bei fünf.
Gut das könnte natürlich dafür sprechen dass die schwedischen zahlen massiv unterschätzt werden so das könnte noch interessant werden wo
wo man dann am ende landet aber in der tat bei der wenn man von der zahl der toten ausgeht ja.
Das ist beunruhigend die offiziellen zahlen zumindest vom trend her sehen jetzt nicht so beunruhigend aus aber ja.
Wer weiß.
Spitzenreiter bleibt die usa ganz klar aber auch hier muss man immer wieder sagen wenn man das mal mit der eu vergleicht.
Also e u gesamt steht da auch nicht besser da als die usa von daher ist es eine etwas schwieriges bild trotzdem.
Entwickelte sich dann nicht gut was insbesondere die zahl der toten betrifft weil die ist auch hoch.
Ja man muss aber sagen im moment also sie haben bei den infizierten zahlen haben sie den höhepunkt
schon überschritten und bei dem zuwachs und es sieht so aus auch bei den toten scheint jetzt der gipfel
überschritten zu sein so dass es jetzt in
mein prognosen jetzt so auf ja siebzigtausend ungefähr rausläuft.
Würde ich sagen aber mit noch einer gewissen schwankungsbreite und auf eine million gesamt in der spitze wenn das jetzt so weiterläuft aber gesagt usa.
Die kurven sehen noch recht steil aus aber
zumindest zeigen auch dort die maßnahmen
wirkung des des kann man schon mal sagen und es lange zeit sah es ja so aus als wenn das da völlig ungebremst wächst.
Der trend scheint gebrochen zu sein aber also es besteht hoffnung für die für die usa dass das nicht zur komplett katastrophe wird trotz des präsidenten.
Gut wollen wir dann mal auf den zweiten großen blog zu sprechen kommen die sache.
Mit den tracing ups das hat auch in den letzten tagen in der medialen berichterstattung eine enorme fahrt aufgenommen vielleicht nochmal der blick auf unsere letzte sendung was ich ja dort gemacht habe ist ich habe mal auseinander genommen.
Wie das system,
funktionieren könnte auf basis der von apple und google gemeinsam angekündigten technischen initiative von denen sie ja auch gesagt haben dass sie das jetzt schnellstmöglich.
In ihrer betriebssysteme auf den smartphones einbauen wollen also bei apple ist das natürlich.
Für iphones etcetera also wie gesagt ich vor allem um die alfons und bei google natürlich android.
Und die ganze diskussion wie funktioniert dieses protokoll etcetera basierte darauf gleich mal von vornherein klarzumachen.
Jetzt haben wir in deutschland seit einigen wochen eine initiative gehabt mit dem.
Locker von der zunge gehenden namen p p strich p pan european privacy reservix proximal tracing.
Wo ich mir schon dachte so auf weil also das.
Also das wird schon schwierig da den richtigen hashtag zu finden.
Geschweige denn ihn richtig einzugeben das hat sich auch gezeigt bindestrich in solchen namen sind sowieso eine ganz schlechte idee.
Und es gab lange zeit ein ziemliche verwirrung was denn nun eigentlich bei diesem projekt herauskommen soll beziehungsweise welchen technischen ansatz die denn eigentlich verfolgen.
Und am anfang zeichnete sich das so ab dass sie.
Auch ein dezentralen ansatz haben.
Der aus dem auch schön formulierten protokoll mit dem bezeichnung.
Weiß ich gar nicht was ganz also die abkürzung ist drei also das drei steht dann wiederum für drei ps also eine katastrophe.
Das war sozusagen der eine ansatz hieß aber da immer dass sie irgendwie mehrere wege verfolgen.
Im wesentlichen zwei wo sie am evaluieren sind und mittlerweile hat sich.
Da ein split vollzogen das heißt es sind zahlreiche.
Forschungsinstitute einzelne forscher aus diesem projekt ausgetreten.
Zürich helmholz diverse gruppen haben sich dort teilweise auch lautstark unter protest aus diesem projekt verabschiedet
weil sich innerhalb dieses so ein bisschen der trend durchgesetzt hat dass sie eben nicht auf dieses
dezentrale protokoll sondern stattdessen auf ein zentrales protokoll setzen wollen.
Problem war bis zum letzten freitag war dieses protokoll noch in keiner form veröffentlicht,
es wurde also irgendwie entwickelt und es gab so ein paar white papers wo so vollmundig und auf der webseite in so allgemein phrasen formuliert wurde so ja alles total privacy und so weiter.
Aber da fehlte einfach butter bei die fische.
Und von den revolutionierenden gruppen gab's dann einigen druck der dann wohl dazu geführt hat oder vielleicht haben sie es auch eh vor der dazu zu geführt hat dass sie sich jetzt mal ein bisschen nackig gemacht haben und jetzt,
ein entsprechendes paper in dem dann verhältnismäßig klar mal definiert ist was sie eigentlich konkret sich unter diesem zentralen system vorstellen.
Ja und dieser splitt ist aber trotzdem vollzogen und es.
Dann auch von den leuten die halt den dezentralen ansatz verfolgen wollen und auch immer noch pushen auch ein detailliertes paypal schon vorher wo sie beschreiben wie sie das machen und mittlerweile gibt es auch einen kritik.
Hier an diesem zentralen ansatz der eben eine bewertung liefert was denn dieses zentrale,
irgendwie angeblich tut und was ihr aus ihrer sicht her daran falsch ist.
Das ganze ist politisch auch irgendwie interessant aufgehängt ohne dass ich da jetzt zu viel details
weiß aber es zeichnet sich so ab dass dieser zentrale ansatz auch der favorit der regierung zu sein scheint also dass die.
Sich quasi hinter dieses zentrale modell stellt aus welchen gründen auch immer.
Und zwar nicht nur die politik in deutschland sondern auch die politik in frankreich denn dieses sogenannte pan european in diesem projekt namen suggeriert ja so ein bisschen dass man einen
eine lösung für europa findet dass man also nicht allein eine nationalen ansatz hier verfolgt sondern schon irgendwie gemerkt hat dass europa ja aus mehreren staaten besteht und,
das wird so viel movement,
tier ja eigentlich haben dass es sehr sinnvoll ist nicht auf verschiedene systeme zu setzen und im wesentlichen sieht es so aus als ob das halt erstmal heißt.
Es gibt.
Eine deutsche initiative und es gibt eine französische initiative die im wesentlichen ein irgendwie kompatiblen ansatz fahren.
Aber tatsächlich im detail auch nochmal technisch anders implementiert sind.
Also das mal so ein bisschen als prolog für die ganze geschichte und mit diesen ganzen abkürzungen ist es auch schwierig den überblick zu behalten.
Ich will jetzt mal versuchen zu erklären.
Wie dieses zentrale system an sich gedacht ist und bevor ich das mache rufe ich nochmal ganz kurz wach was ich in der letzten sendung so ausführlich dargestellt habe.
Also den apple google ansatz der im übrigen.
Ziemlich genau dasselbe implementiert wie auch diese dezentrale gruppe diese vormals im pc mitarbeitende gruppe also das d drei p das.
Dezentrale protokoll was ich es ausgeklinkt hat aus diesem anderen projekt hat eigentlich im wesentlichen dasselbe.
Im ziel also wenn ich habe mir dieses whitepaper durchgelesen von diesem drei p t.
Und im wesentlichen ist das dasselbe in grün also die haben diese dasselbe modell die haben dasselbe konzept und teilweise auch.
Identische soweit ich das verstanden habe entweder identische oder zumindest so natur tische konzept
so also sie sagen auch in ihren öffentlichen bekundungen so der ansatz mit apple und google darum damit können wir arbeiten,
wir haben da zwar noch ein paar vorschläge wie wir das ganz gerne noch anders hätten aber das sind eher so details die sind vielleicht am ende des
aber das sind so eher so wünsche mit naja könnte nicht das und das noch ein bisschen so und so und so machen weil dann wäre es aus unserer sicht noch ein bisschen privatsphäre schonender und noch ein bisschen sicherer gegen bestimmte vorstellbar attacken
aber das prinzip ist es gleich und das prinzip ist kurz gesagt alle telefone die daran teilnehmen die also diese app installiert haben.
Senden selber all dies.
Empfangen all dies von anderen telefon die all dies die sie senden basieren auf einer krypto die auf dem telefon stattfindet.
In dem moment wo jemand als infiziert gemeldet wird veröffentlicht man die liste der selbst gesendeten all dies.
Die in die wolke von dort regnen sie auf alle anderen telefone herab und jedes telefon kann selber sich dann diese dinge anschauen.
Okay hier ist ein infizierten habe ich den gesehen und wenn ja alarm das ist im prinzip die idee dabei und es ist.
Aus meiner perspektive ein relativ eleganter.
Ansatz denn vor allem in großen vorteil hat dass jedes gerät quasi seine krypto selber macht und bestimmte informationen nämlich dieses was habe ich eigentlich gesehen.
Dieses telefon nicht verlässt man bekommt nur die information wer von denen die nicht gesehen habe könnte quasi infiziert sein weil es als infiziert gemeldet und dann kann ich selber nachgucken okay habe ich den gesehen.
Die idee.
Also man kann vielleicht zusammenfassen auch dass das vermutlich die privatsphäre schonendste variante ist die gerade noch das ziel erreicht kontakte zu tresen also viel
privatsphäre schonender geht es eigentlich nicht.
Naja jetzt macht es so den eindruck dass hier noch ein.
Zweiter faktor mit reinkommt den wir so auch bisher gar nicht besprochen haben oder ein zweiter wunsch weil er eine wunsch ist halt kontakte feststellen leute waren.
Das deckt dieses apple google ding ab der zweite wunsch ist.
Wir möchten gerne während wir das tun auch eine maximale ausbeute an logisch auswertbar daten generieren.
Wir wollen ein möglichst guten überblick über diese kontaktabbruch folge bekommen wir wollen informationen darüber gewinnen.
Wer mit wem und auf welche art und weise um
all diese dinge vielleicht herausfinden zu können über die wir jetzt vorher auch schon besprochen haben bezug auf die manuelle auswertung weil es gibt ja diesen prozess der nachverfolgen und das digitale system soll ja diese nach verfolgung verbessern beschleunigen.
Das ist die große hoffnung die darin steckt und es macht jetzt so den eindruck als ob eben dieser wunsch noch mehr epidemiologische auswertung zu haben diese gruppe dazu gebracht hat ein anderes modell zu propagieren.
Eben dieses zentrale modell wie funktioniert das jetzt auch hier gibt es im zentrum natürlich eine app die man sich herunterlädt.
Und startet und sagt ich möchte jetzt gerne an diesem ganzen brimborium teilnehmen.
Anders als in den dezentralen modell wird aber jetzt hier nicht.
Die krypto gemacht und man fängt sofort an zu senden und zu empfangen und später kann man mal gucken wer so gemeldet wurde und dann fange ich an zu vergleichen sondern in diesem zentralen modell.
Hat die app eigentlich eine andere rolle was sie auch macht ist,
sie sendet und empfängt diese bluethoothspeaker also an der stelle so kommt dieselbe technologie zum einsatz also die idee die technische protokolle idee ist die gleiche man sendet halt diese funk feuer aus und sammelt irgendwie ein und gewinnt
sozusagen damit eben diese diese pärchen letzten endes jetzt die frage wo kommen diese.
Daten eigentlich hier die ich versende dezentralen modell hat man halt diesen.
Master kiel aus dem man sich einen täglichen kiel machen aus diesem täglichen kiel generiert man eine liste von kies die man über den tag verteilt so aussendet,
man dann am ende nur diese tageskrise veröffentlicht alle anderen können dann sehen okay aus dem leiten sich folgende all dies ab habe ich die gesehen wenn ja dann alarm
hier ist es jetzt in dem zentralen modell so dass man eben dieses ganze matching.
Wer hat denn jetzt wen gesehen nicht auf dem telefon macht sondern im backend in der wolke und.
Wenn diese app jetzt startet macht sie als erstes folgendes die erzeugt sich selber erstmal eine idee.
So eine persistent damit wird quasi diese app oder dieses telefon als teilnehmer in dem system geboren.
Und vergibt sich sozusagen selber so eine universell gültige aldi.
Jetzt meldet sich die app an der wolke an und sagt hallo ich will teilnehmen registriere mich doch mal und dann kommt die wolke.
Und sagt okay hallo du möchtest also hier einen account anlegen den habe ich dir jetzt mal eingerichtet und dann gibt die wolke dem telefon.
Die kies zum aussenden für die nächste zeit das heißt das was in dem dezentralen modell auf dem telefon stattfindet.
Findet jetzt in der wolke statt das heißt die wolke gibt mir die kies und sie gibt mir die kies für die nächsten tage in diesem paper steht sowas wie.
Zum beispiel für die nächsten vier tage das bedeutet aber auch.
Ich muss halt auch regelmäßig immer wieder die wolke um neue kies fragen damit ich die raussenden kann jetzt sende ich dir raus.
Andere telefone sehen die speichern das entsprechend ab jetzt haben wir wieder diesen infektionsforschung personen kriegst im thomé.
Lässt sich testen stellt fest rona.
Und durch einen ähnlich gelagerten prozess wie wir das letzte woche auch besprochen haben für das andere protokoll geht man halt durch so einen offiziellen weg lässt sich halt irgendwie freischalten dass man sagen kann.
Ich bin jetzt auch infiziert im dezentralen modell gibt man dann quasi seine eigenen kies die man in den letzten vierzehn tagen gesendet hat frei hier.
Läuft's andersrum hier gibt das telefon des infizierten die gesehenen.
All dies der anderen telefone in die wolke damit dann in der wolke geguckt werden kann.
Wer ist denn das das heißt dieses ganze matching findet.
In der wolke statt und deswegen muss auch die wolke vorher diese kies rausgeben weil sie dir sonst nicht zuordnen könnte das heißt die wolke sagt den telefon was soll sie raus senden ein anderes telefon empfängt diese.
Der ist ein infiziert und sagt hier die habe ich gesehen und dann weiß das system die aldi da weiß ich genau welches telefon dazugehört weil ich habe diese kies selber erzeugt.
Das ist im prinzip das modell dieses zentralen ansatzes und man verspricht sich davon dass man dann in dem moment ja.
Alle kontakte sieht und ein besseres verständnis für diesen verteilungskurve das heißt einer meldet sich und man sieht sofort alle die irgendwie,
muss ich darauf warten dass diese anderen sich auch erst wieder melden weil im dezentralen modell gibt es dann erstmal eine warnung und bevor die sich nicht selber auch irgendwie als infiziert melden sind man die halt gar nicht.
Aber in dem zentralen modell werden sozusagen pseudonym ich würde das nicht mehr als anonym bezeichnen pseudonym klar ermittelt wer ist davon gesehen worden.
Ganz unabhängig davon ob die leute jetzt auch sich den virus eingefangen haben oder nicht.
Und das hat jetzt eine ganze reihe von implikationen dieses modell da fängt schon mal die sache an.
Bei der erstellung dieses ersten accounts weil das system hält jetzt sozusagen accounts vor also in dieser wolke ist extrem viel intelligenz.
Wenn in dieser wolke eine datenkommunikation löschung verschiebung modifikation entweder durch softwareverteilung oder durch
hacker von außen oder oder was auch immer in dem moment die datenquelle ist datenverlust und so weiter wenn das wegfällt fällt die ganze intelligenz auseinander.
Und man muss auch verhindern dass ich nicht irgendwelche akteure melden die gar keine telefone sind.
Weil da kommt dann irgendwas im internet und sagt hallo ich bin ein telefon ich möchte gerne kies haben dich durch die gegend senden kann und was ist wenn ich jetzt einfach so eine bottermelk habe die einfach sich da meldet und sagt hallo ich bin's.
Ja okay die haben dann so zertifikat penning und security und so weiter aber wissen alle diese security kann auch fehlen und da haben sie ja von vornherein schon mal in diesen anmeldeprozess vorgesehen.
Dass wenn ich jetzt die app installieren und die starte das dann erstmal so ein capture hochkommt.
Steht da wirklich so direkt in dieser spezifikation drin dass dein capture kommt also ein beweise mir dass du ein mensch bist
ding wir kennen das alle klicken sie die ampeln an und wo sind die hydranten und sowas ja was sind nicht ob sie es das nehmen wollen oder irgendwas anderes und zusätzlich noch.
Ein sogenannter proof of work das heißt man.
Dann auch noch so eine zahl rein und sagt so hier liebes telefon du musst mal mit diesem algorithmus da jetzt mal zehn sekunden drin rum rechnen.
Und uns das ergebnis liefern was wir dann überprüfen können und dadurch dass wir diese algorithmus funktioniert kann man dazu sagen sicherstellen dass dieses telefon so und so viel zeit damit verbringt.
Damit wollen sie sozusagen so 'ne massenkakao erzeugung von vornherein irgendwie verhindern also man sieht schon im ersten schritt.
Ist man schon voll in der defensive also es ist sozusagen bevor überhaupt irgendetwas stattfindet ist dieses system schon sich bewusst
das ist hier zu einer extremen verzerrung kommen kann weil wenn du es jetzt auf einmal schaffst eine millionen accounts anzulegen dann kriegst du halt von dem system irgendwelche.
Gemeldet und ein anderer kann man sagen ja ich bin jetzt hier irgendwie infiziert und dann kann man da eben auch wieder die ganzen all dies wieder reinmachen die so nie kontakt miteinander hatten.
Das ist schon mal so ein problem bei diesem ganzen ding zweites problem ist dass dieses.
Mitteilen von den ganzen kontakten der wolke ein extrem überblick über dieses wer mit wem gibt.
Und zwar ganz unabhängig davon ob die leute infiziert sind oder nicht ja jetzt kann man natürlich argumentieren naja aber bei uns in der wolke ist ja alles ganz sicher,
nur jeder weiß dass wenn man eben
da viele daten gewinnt und bei hohen infektionsbad wird es dann halt auch exponentiell immer mehr weil man immer mehr kontakte von kontakt
und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe das sagt zumindest dieses analyse papier von der dezentralen gruppe wer es dann eben auch in zunehmenden maße möglich die identitäten wieder zurück zu rechnen weil das ist sozusagen so ein faktor den man kennt
wenn man erstmal genug fälle betrachtet von wer mit wem dann kann man da relativ schnell gruppen
ausmachen wer hat viel miteinander zu tun etcetera und das ist ein problem was da drin steckt.
Und man kann diese daten natürlich auch wunderbar kombinieren dann mit ich sag mal kommerziellen tracking daten die alle möglichen anderen
apps so sammeln was weiß ich tinder hat irgendwie gleich drei verschiedene tracker mit
eingebaut die sie bedienen und viele andere apps auch plus natürlich apple und google wissen natürlich auch sagen wo das telefon ist und da kann man dann,
eben sagen auch über die die korrelation ist sollte es kein problem.
Seinen großteil der identitäten aufzudecken inklusive wohnsitz also wo halten die sich überwiegend auf und
so in investment nee und so und ja das ist natürlich nicht akzeptabel.
Ganz grundsätzlich muss man ja ein ein problem einfach mal insoliert betrachten diese telefone erhalten eine all die.
Wissen nicht welche krypto dahinter steckt.
Und senden die raus andere senden die sammeln die ein und dann ganze geht das ganze zur überprüfung am ende wieder in die cloud und nur dort laufen die fäden zusammen.
Diese aldi richtig erzeugt wurde unter welchen parametern.
Diese aldi erzeugt wurde welche informationen in dieser aldi alle noch mit eingerechnet wurden kann diese app und damit dieses telefon nicht überprüfen.
Wenn du jetzt sozusagen da ein evil player mit im spiel hast und das soll ja bei staaten durchaus auch mal vorkommen.
Dann könntest du halt sagen naja also hier die person die interessiert mich aber schon oder diese community diese gruppe interessiert mich jetzt aber auch mal besonders da rechnen wir nochmal so ein paar bits einfach mit in diesen kira rein.
Die jetzt dieser app so nicht auffallen weil das sind für die einfach nur irgendwelche bits wenn du nicht weißt was drinsteckt kannst du das von außen auch nicht sehen.
Aber du kannst natürlich diesen käse gestalten dass ein beliebiger beobachter also.
Irgendwelche bluetooth empfangen devices in bahnhöfen in flughäfen in firmen wo auch immer diese sehen und sie nicht einfach nur als irgendeine random.
Aldi von der keiner weiß was dahinter steckt sieht sondern kann unter umständen diese information extrahieren und weiß ganz genau ah ja okay.
Das ist dieses telefon das meldet sich mit dieser ip-adresse holt sich regelmäßig irgendwie seine daten ab,
diesen account dann und dann erzeugt also das ist ja da sind so viele meter daten in diesem ganzen prozess drin wie ist dieser capture kram abgelaufen wann hat sich das angemeldet unter welchen bedingungen aus welchen letzten holt sich das ding das irgendwie raus ja eine app
könnte ja theoretisch auch noch begleiten formation mitliefern das heißt wenn man da sozusagen die entsprechende kriminelle energie hat ist es natürlich schon
vorstellbar sagte die haben das vor aber es ist sozusagen vorstellbar in diesem modell dass man eben bestimmte gruppen.
Nach region was auch immer nach ip-adressen die man irgendwie kennt oder auch nicht ausfindig machen und den einfach ein bestimmtes tag noch mitgibt und dieses
ist halt über machbar an antworten an der stelle hast du halt wirklich ein instrument mit dem eine überwachung möglich ist.
Ich würde es ja in geldautomaten einbauen die haben bestimmt auch bluetooth und haben eine kamera und wenn du dein geld abhebst,
sagen kann dann,
blicken gleich sagt mit deinem konto assoziiert werden und ein snapchat gemacht werden wer denn da gerade geld abhebt mit dem telefon und dann hast du gleich das passende bild und.
Die kontodaten und letzte.
Okay du siehst die all die weiß wen sie rausgegeben wurde du hast die verbindung und damit
damit kannst du dann beim nächsten den gehaltene aldi da reinkopieren und das dann eben an der bluetooth selber ansehen genau also das da gibt's einfach wenn man erstmal anfängt über diesen vektor nachzudenken
kommt man sehr schnell auf eine ganze menge ideen wie man das denn so nutzen könnte wenn man denn ein evil player ist.
Und nun geht es natürlich in dieser ganzen diskussion vor allem um vertrauen vertrauen vertrauen vertrauen wir wollen einfach ausschließen.
Dass ein missbrauch möglich ist ich will dir nicht unterstellen dass sie das so design dass ein missbrauch möglich ist.
Überhaupt nicht ich denke das sind alles leute die am here ziele und die wollen irgendwie das richtige tun und die wollen eben auch diesen aspekt.
Naja wenn wir diesen kontakt grafen uns nur näher anschauen können das wäre ja so wertvoll ja opfern aber auf diesem altar sozusagen,
ein wichtigen teil dieser privatsphäre der vielleicht für das vertrauen in das ganze system entscheidend ist.
Ich habe das ja schon gesehen als ich als apple google protokoll rauskam ich mir das mal angeschaut habe habe ich fitter halt auch gesagt leute das ist eine chance irgendwie das meiner meinung nach kann das funktionieren und da gab es eine menge leute auch so aus meiner wolke heraus
die hat gesagt haben ich vertraue hier irgendwie überhaupt kein und die wollen uns alle nur aushorchen und
ab jetzt findest du es noch toll aber später findet man da irgendwie einen angriffspunkt und so und ich kann auch gar nicht ausschließen dass nicht irgendein super finde mensch auch bei diesem dezentralen ding noch irgendwas findet was irgendwo.
Denkbar wäre ja aber es fällt mir schon sehr schwer und wir haben ja auch über diese ganzen sachen auch schon
ansatzweise gesprochen und eigentlich immer wieder festgestellt ja theoretisch könnte man mit irgendeinem aufwand was machen
der aber nur ein sehr begrenztes
affekt hat ne also es kam auch in den kommentaren sowas wie naja aber dann kann ich ja irgendwie leuten da hinterher laufen und mit viel aufwand ihre all dies einsammeln und so weiter und dann kann ich sie irgendwie übers internet schicken und irgendeiner anderen stelle gleichzeitig mit
brotkasten oder tagelang weiter brotkasten auch da gibt's übrigens eine grenze weil man kann mit diesem daily sieht man nicht nur welche kieswerk erzeugt sondern da ist auch noch so ein time intervall mit drin das heißt man,
jeder dieser kies gilt auch wirklich nur genau in diesen fünfzehn minuten slots
und würde er später auch noch verwendet werden könnte man ihn sofort raus sortieren als der ist fake.
Also da ist schon auch nochmal eine gewisse sicherheit drin die welt so letzte mal gar nicht besprochen haben nur in diesem zentralen modell sind solche schutzmechanismen
komplett weg weil die ganze krypto ist in der wolke du musst der kompletten wolke vertrauen um dieser krypto zu vertrauen.
Und ganz ehrlich also da gehe ich nicht so richtig mit bezüglich dieses wunsch ist.
Mehr daten über diesen kontakt grafen zu bekommen das kann ja auch verstehen
ja also wenn man jetzt also als videolog es dadrauf schaut oder auch als bundesregierung und sagt wir müssen jetzt mehr verstehen wir wollen mehr verstehen ja,
wir wollen ja auch dass sie mehr davon verstehen haben wir ja auch schon lange und breit ausgebreitet dass das
dass dass wir das wollen dass dieses wollen so und jetzt wollen sie das auch und sehen auf einmal diese app als eine möglichkeit mit so einem hals versprechen na ja so ein bisschen privatsphäre ist doch schon drin lass uns das mal so machen.
Aber.
Die drei leute also die dezentralen sage ich mal von diesem projekt die sich da ausgeklinkt haben die sagen halt auch so,
na ja gut wir verstehen das und es ist auch nicht so unmöglich das zu machen auf freiwilligkeit.
Weil in dem moment wo dein telefon sagt du bist in kontakt gewesen mit jemandem der als infiziert gemeldet ist am um.
Stufe eins so sagst du ne ich sage einen ganzen tag in der wohnung.
Kann nicht sein okay dann kannst du es innovieren oder du warst ja unsicher naja ich war auch mal im supermarkt verweis vielleicht hat das ja schon was gebracht lässt sich testen bist nicht infiziert.
Lässt auch gar keine daten in die wolke.
Trotzdem hast diese warnung bekommen und dann könnt ihr die app ja immer noch sagen hör mal wir hatten zwar jetzt die warnung du bist zwar jetzt ja auch nicht infektiös so der test war negativ möchtest du uns trotzdem.
Eine anonymisierte information irgendeiner gestalt quasi spenden da sind wir wieder bei diesem punkt der datenspeicher.
Dass man sagt so ja okay dieser vorfall den den den melde ich mal anonym weg damit ihr sozusagen auch eine rückmeldung habt mit okay habe ich zur kenntnis genommen ich habe habe diese warnung auch also null auch die app wurde sozusagen benutzt und
die perfektion wurde angezeigt ja auch eine interessante information und bei mir war aber nix sowas kann man da immer noch einbauen.
Aber eben auf basis eines eines vertrauens levels indem man sagt so okay das sind jetzt hier die information die anonym durchgereicht werden etcetera das kann man auch was mal weglassen.
Lange rede kurzer sinn ich habe meine zweifel das andere ding ist technisch.
Lässt sich das was die da vorhaben nicht machen weil ohne die unterstützung von dem betriebssystem für diesen modus ja
läuft da mal gar nichts weil du kannst mir,
die ganze zeit nach bluethoothspeaker fahrenden das ist eine funktion die zumindest bei apple komplett zugemacht ist und bei anderen soweit ich weiß auch mit restriktionen verbunden ist die ich jetzt aber nicht konkret benennen kann
bei apple ist es relativ unmöglich du kannst das nicht im background machen und du kannst dich beliebige all dies einsammeln du brauchst auf zu explizit den support des betriebssystems
und jetzt gibt es wohl druck also da werden gespräche geführt.
Ich stelle mir das so vor dass da die staaten gerade bei apple und google anrufen und den die hölle heiß machen und sagen hier wir wollen aber hier die epidemie mal eindämmen und wir haben uns was ganz schickes ausgedacht wie wär's denn mal baut das doch mal ein.
Sonst haben wir euch nicht mehr lieb so und ihr wisst wie sehr wir euch nicht lieb haben können mit irgendwelchen anderen.
Regularien keine ahnung was auch immer sie da jetzt für argumente vorbringen ja ich will jetzt gar nichts unterstellen aber.
So ich weiß nicht so also eine auseinandersetzung wird sicherlich mit argumenten und mit gewichten geführt
und diese firmen stehen jetzt sozusagen vor der wahl entweder da knallhart zu bleiben und zu sagen so nee das ist uns zu unsicher.
Wir senden nicht hier irgendwelche aus einer irgendeiner wolke.
Bereitgestellten all dies aus und sammeln die auch noch ein und machen die telefonier zusammen zu so einem datensammlung für euer komisches konzept was verschiedene angriff vektoren hat die uns überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Wo man schon im allerersten schritt merkt was was ihr dafür probleme verhindern müsst um damit es nicht gleich bevor es das erste datenpaket ausgesendet hat um zu kippen und wir bleiben da hart.
Mein tipp ist.
Das ist das was wir sehen werden also ich kann mir beim besten willen nicht vorstellen dass apple und google gemeinsam.
Vor allem wegen apple aber ich denke auch bei google haben die das problem schon verstanden die werden sich einfach da nicht umstimmen lassen sondern sie werden einfach sagen.
Sorry das fällt am ende alles auf uns zurück das ist ein schaden den können wir uns überhaupt nicht leisten ja wir sind davon überzeugt.
Dass man das primäre ziel nämlich warnung von menschen und.
Schnelleres verfolgen von ausbreitung dass man das mit dieser methode relativ einfach erzielen kann.
Und das bauen wir jetzt ein und wenn sich jetzt irgendwie deutschland und frankreich da auf die hinterbeine stellen sagen.
Aber sowas machen wir nicht weil wir haben jetzt hier auch unsere projektgruppe ist immer bei dem beispiel von vorhin und die haben sich jetzt hier schön in dieses ding verrant und wir auch und wir jammern jetzt noch drei wochen und nochmal nochmal einen monat länger rum,
bis ihr uns endlich unser eis gibt dann wird einfach wieder wertvolle zeit verloren.
Man hätte jetzt eigentlich die möglichkeit relativ easy mit dem support von apple und google ein meiner meinung nach ziemlich gutes system.
Zu erhalten umzusetzen und sehr schnell zu ergebnissen zu kommen das ding ist während ich bei dem einen apple installiere und dann muss diese ganze cloud stehen alles dieses ganze melde wesen.
Alles muss fertig programmiert getestet sein security getestet sein das muss irgendwie eine enorme last
haben weil alle kleinste die ganze zeit nach kies schreien gib mir kies gib mir kies gib mir kies ja die wollen die ganze zeit was permanente
count geflackert und und und und bedienung von von von telefon da muss alles richtig sein da darf nichts falsches rausgegeben werden wenn da irgendwas falsch läuft können sie die kompletten datenbestand wegschmeißen das muss alles funktionieren bevor man überhaupt
anfangen kann während das modell das apple google modell bedeutet im wesentlichen es gibt ein betriebssystem-update du kriegst einen schalter.
Da steht contact tracing einschalten und die telefone fangen heute an alles zu traden bevor die app überhaupt da ist.
Weil die brauchen diese app nicht um ihre kernfunktionen zu machen die erzeugen ihre kies selber die senden selber die fangen ein und speichern das ab die haben genug speicher.
Die können die letzten vierzehn tage vorhalten kein problem dann schmeißen sie daten wieder weg und wenn du dann die app installiert und sagst hallo ich bin's die offizielle nationale contact tracing app von deutschland.
Dann kriegt ihr das fleck im app store dass sie überhaupt auf dieses ganze subsystemen zugreifen darf dann kommt die irgendwie hoch und dann sagt er so
ich bin jetzt übrigens da ich wollte mal gucken was hier eigentlich passiert ist bei euch und und du hast sozusagen schon vierzehn tage sowas allein schon deshalb schon mal zwei wochen gewonnen.
Und dann ist es sozusagen in anführungsstrichen nur noch erforderlich dieses meldeweg lesen am start zu kriegen was er auch in dem zentralisiertes modell genauso.
Unter denselben bedingungen auch machen muss nur das andere daten übermittelt werden also das war schon wirklich ein ein ein harter marsch durch durch dieses durch diese pepper durchzugehen und ich muss sagen ich.
Verstehe diesen weg nicht und ich.
Denke da rennt man einfach gegen eine wand das ist einfach ist es auch so schwer dass zu verstehen dass alles zu lesen.
Ich glaube ja es ist eine sackgasse und eine totbestand geburt weil selbst ich sag mal wenn,
sie apple und google dazu bringen könnten irgendwie ihnen diese funktionalität zu öffnen wo ich auch eher glaube ich meine,
apple hat halt sich sehr erfolgreich jeden druck der us-regierung widersetzt irgendwelche schwachstellen sagen einzubauen oder auch behilflich zu sein irgendwie also.
Von daher sehe ich sehe ich das sehe ich das ähnlich und.
Selbst wenn sie das irgendwie auf andere art und weise machen gut bei google die kontrollieren jetzt nicht nicht ganz so genau was bei denen in ihrem playstore landet
aber bei apple sagen durch den review zu kommen vor allem durch den.
Initialen review zu kommen das ist schon nicht ganz ohne ja dass das dauert auch auch eine weile aber.
Selbst wenn sie das irgendwie hinkriegen sollten glaube ich wird einfach die nutzung
dieser app aufgrund der bedenken deutlich unter dem liegen was beim anderen ansatz.
Gemacht würde und es ist ja nach wie vor gesagt freiwillig wobei das mit der freiwilligkeit denn auch
so eine sache sein kann da das war auch noch nicht was wenn sie sagen da gab es ja auch schon befürchtungen dass dann zugang zu bestimmten veranstaltungen oder anderen
oder oder orten davon abhängig gemacht werden könnte dass man halt einen telefon mit einer app
dabei hat oder sich dann anderweitig identifizieren muss ich immer nicht hatte noch so das vergnügen.
Kurz lang vor der schließung der restaurants aber als schon irgendwie die abstandsregelung galten
war ich essen und da wurde dann im lokal saßen auch alle schön
irgendwie weit voneinander weg jeder zweite tisch war als reserviert bezeichnet aber
so es ging dann eine liste rum wo man halt einen kontakt hinterlassen musste so eine telefonnummer oder eine e-mail adresse oder sowas um dann.
Erreichbar zu sein falls sich irgendwie rausstellt dass dort in dem laden ist eine infektion gab oder so so.
Lief das halt und so kann ich mir vorstellen dass es zumindest in der gastronomie vielleicht auch weiter
laufen könnte und das problem löst aber diese app.
Hier dann auch wiederum nicht nicht wirklich plus.
Für solche fälle ist sind auch diese bluethoothspeaker wiederum nicht so gut geeignet weil wenn jemand irgendwie fünfte schon weiter saß so sollte der eigentlich nicht mehr als kontakt.
Wirklich identifiziert werden was aber wiederum eine ansteckung nicht ausschließt also ja.
Wie dem auch sei ich finde das sehr bedauerlich diesen.
Diesen streit und insbesondere auch dass man versucht dort jetzt ein system zu pushen was,
ja so nichts ganzes und nichts halbes ist weil.
Eigentlich wirst du schon sagst okay wir spielen spenden daten oder wir wollen irgendwie,
datengetriebenen dann möchte ich noch viel mehr und andere daten gewinnen dann möchte ich irgendwie auch noch die geologen aktion und keine ahnung da möchte ich auch dass der benutzer irgendwie zwischendurch noch eingaben
macht oder so vielleicht plus ich glaube das system,
wird dann weil es natürlich auch
sondern prominenten angriff punkt darstellt wird angegriffen werden und wird erfolgreich angegriffen werden was die da jetzt mit.
Und mit proof of the work machen also das schreckt kein ernsthaften angreifer an ich mein profi offen,
telefon ich meine da setze ich eine von meinen grafikkarten an die macht halt
das hechingen so hundert mal so schnell wie ein telefon so wenn das telefon zehn sekunden braucht dann kann ich halt im zehntel sekundentakt und ich habe drei von den grafikkarten also kann ich irgendwie mir
kann ich halt dann dreißig mal pro sekunde da proof of work machen.
Da steht da noch genug rum von der ersten generation bitcoin meiner wo sie alles auf grafikkarten gemacht haben die haben sie alle noch im schrank also.
Ja
also es kannst du ja alles das wird den puffer vorhat kannst du auch einfach gleich sein lassen das ist ja das ist völlig franz und kappt
ich bitte dich
was wollen die denn im bitte schön jetzt für einen für einen capture einbauen abgesehen davon dass ich irgendwie häufiger an caps scheitere als irgendwie meine bilderkennung
so es ist.
Genau klicken sie alle ampel an welcher ampeln.
Also es ist also das ist unseriös so
was sie da als angebliche schutzmaßnahme verkaufen das schreckt kein ernsthaften angreifer ab und dann.
Ist das ist das ding natürlich.
Dieses sagen kontaktmann da du ja keine geodaten dabei hast die es dir irgendwie ermöglichen sagen das ganze zu,
partizipieren oder so musst du tatsächlich jeden mit jedem vergleichen.
Nee nee das hast du glaube ich das habe ich vielleicht falsch erklärt also wenn wenn jemand als infiziert sich meldet.
Und diesen upload macht sendet der ja die gesehenen kontakte diese bits wie das in diesem system heißt.
An den server die krypto ist so dass die cloud aus diesen all dies die.
Diese als allerallererste generierte dieser app in dem moment wo sich das erste mal startet ja.
Wieder herausrechnen kann das heißt die weiß schon sofort welches telefon das ist und kann dann
auch push-notification direkt an dieses telefon raus sind also da ist jetzt kein komplexere vorgang der dran also diese identifizierung des telefons bis hin zu ich bin in der lage dir direkt auf dieses telefon eine push-notification zu senden
das ist dann quasi schon teil des kryptografisch prinzips.
Okay sozusagen die identität des telefons ist eigentlich kryptografisch in jedem einzelnen dieken drin oh.
Aber halt eben also das system hat ich habe das jetzt nicht so im detail ausgeführt aber das system generiert jede stunde einen neuen generell.
Also die wolke erzeugt das backend erzeugt ein jede stunde einen neuen kiel.
Damit werden dann sozusagen diese ganzen its.
Berechnet die ändert sich sozusagen am laufenden meter aber da fließt halt diese persistent aldi der app mit rein der tag und die zeit und die ist da sozusagen mit.
Eingerechnet und dieser andere kiel der sich am laufenden meter ändert und
das wird dann dem telefon gegeben so die gucken sozusagen auch in die zukunft und berechnet das schon mal für die nächsten vier tage vor und dann kommt das telefon und sagt hallo meine all dies sind alle was soll ich jetzt senden.
Und dann muss sie sich halt an die wolke wenden und die muss dann eben auch response
so also wenn das ding irgendwie down ist weiß ich wenn ich jetzt mein telefon mal ein paar tage kein internet gesehen hat warum auch immer dann kann es halt theoretisch sein es wird wahrscheinlich faktisch nicht so passieren aber.
Vom modell her ist es vorstellbar dass ein telefon wenn es nicht keine keine gelegenheit hatte diesen server zu erreichen aus welchen gründen auch immer irgendwann gar nicht mehr weiß was es senden soll.
Weil.
Hängt immer an an diesem versorgungs- der wolke aber die die ich bekomme nehme ich wie sie ist sende sie zu dem vor bestimmten zeitpunkt aus ändert sich halt auch alle.
Wie bei dem anderen modell auch wird von den anderen telefon gesehen und wenn er halt einer infiziert ist und sich dann meldet wird diese idee die halt über die luft empfangen wurde rausgesendet
und da hast du natürlich aber wirklich probleme mit so replay attacken etcetera weil ja.
Also diese security analyse die die die ist schon ziemlich weitreichend und ziemlich vernichten muss ich auch sagen also wobei das hauptproblem also wirklich.
Ist du kannst halt du hast halt gute ansätze um den social graf
von jemandem in dem moment auch zu detektieren und was ich persönlich eben als das größte problem sehe.
Ist halt einfach dieses von also dass du in diesem kiel eigentlich alles mögliche rein rechnen kannst sie können mir tausend mal sagen was sie angeblich da rein tun ich kann das ja nicht sehen kann einfach sein dass aus irgendwelchen gründen
mir 'ne idee gegeben wird mit der ich sehr wohl tracking bin und an der stelle fand ich das ding schon ein bisschen schwierig
was sie auch noch als problem initiiert haben das ist sogar der erste punkt den sie nennen das.
Das hier prinzip bedingt sozusagen ein hohes potenzial für function creek besteht weil quasi der server alles mögliche.
Das backend alles mögliche beschließen kann was in dieser alles noch mit abgebildet sein soll und sich das sozusagen der skoda immer noch erweitert und erweitert und erweitert.
Ohne dass du irgendwas dagegen tun kannst weil du bist ja eigentlich mit der app nur so ein ja so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein abnehmer von,
identifikations- ja die die wolke sagte die ganze zeit hier ist eine die sendest du jetzt und da wird nicht gefragt was da drin ist.
Viel spaß und es ist halt so.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen wie die leute bei apple security abteilung auf diesen vorschlag gucken die denken sich auch nur so ist nicht euer ernst jetzt oder was.
Wir gehen ja jetzt davon aus dass die auf service-kontakten einfach darüber möglich sind weil auf jeden fall
wenn ich dort erstmal was rein kippe so an
an daten dann läuft erstmal werden erstmal kryptografisch operation durchgeführt ich habe jetzt keine ahnung wie kompliziert oder zeitaufwendig die sind was die da nehmen.
Weißt du da was die da was für eine krypto die da nehmen oder was für.
Das ist hier beschrieben aber das da weiß ich ehrlich gesagt selber zu wenig um das zu interpretieren da bin ich nicht so der experte für.
Aber ganz unabhängig von der krypto.
Dieses system muss einfach die ganze zeit was tun wenn du sagen wir mal zehn millionen smartphones für deutschland durchaus jetzt mal eine relevante größe zehn millionen smartphones nehmen an diesem ding teil.
Das heißt zehn millionen smartphones müssen alle vier tage spätestens mal sich kies berechnen lassen und schicken lassen.
Fünf millionen pro tag kann man sagen okay klar.
Aber dann gucke ich mir halt so an wieso die die server bei den selbstständigen zuschüssen irgendwie alle in die knie gegangen sind wenn er mal so dreitausend leute mal irgendwie fünftausend euro haben wollten und.
Ein web famulatur ausgefüllt haben okay es ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen böse dass so miteinander zu vergleichen aber daran kann man halt sehen solche systeme stehen halt schnell unter stress und die müssen hoch verfügbar immer da sein
während in diesem dezentralen modell.
Alles was die wolke da tun muss die gibt's ja da auch es gibt auch ein backend wo du dein kiel hochlädst aber das ding muss eigentlich nicht mehr tun.
Als dafür zu sorgen dass alle hochgeladenen kies für alle anderen runtergeladen werden können an diesen daten ändert sich nichts.
Die werden nach vierzehn tagen weggeschmissen.
Du kannst die auf beliebig viele cds verteilen du kannst dir in irgendeinem content delivery network reinballern und dann können wir auch von achtzig millionen und achthundert millionen devices runtergeladen werden.
Das ist ein wohlverstandenen problem und es gibt vor allem in dieser wolke nichts groß was kaputt gehen kann
klar du brauchst halt irgendwie eine datenbank muss sicherstellen dass diese kies nicht verloren gehen weil willst ja dass die verteilt werden aber dann kopierst du sie halt irgendwie ausreichend oft die sind aber auch nicht geheim,
das sind keine accounts da sind keine drin die die irgendwie abhanden kommen können da gibt es nichts wo man einbrechen kann du kannst vielleicht dieses system irgendwie aus dem tritt bringen,
aber der mount of code der da irgendwie läuft und kritisch ist der ist sehr sehr sehr überschaubar und ich könnte mir vorstellen dass man so ein system was dieses dezentrale modell braucht also was sozusagen nur kies annimmt da die verifizierung mit dem hell service macht die daten nimmt und sie so ein cdu verteilt
das ist jetzt mal so salopp formuliert naja also für so einen so eine kleine gruppe halbwegs erfahrener leute ist das ding in der woche irgendwie zu machen.
So und dann kannst du schon ins testen gehen und dann testest du nochmal eine woche und dann brauchst du nochmal hier und baust du nochmal da und dann investierst du nochmal ein bisschen was ins deployment und dann.
Dann steht das ding,
aber allein diese komplexität dieses systems mit push-notification service das muss irgendwie alles richtig funktionieren das muss irgendwie skalieren dann hast du da deine datenbank dann hast du auch extrem sichere bereiche da dürfen
die ganzen kies sind da drin die ganzen masterclass generell alles was sozusagen die sicherheit dieses systems ausmacht ist in diesem ding drin
und ist im internet und ist dafür gemacht von.
Millionen von geräten jeden tag permanent befragt zu werden legitimerweise.
Wo du in diesem rauschen von legitimen anfragen in legitimer anfragen wunderbar verstecken kannst.
Die fallen erstmal gar nicht groß auf also musst du da die entsprechenden sicherheitsmaßnahme hoch sind und zwar ein rattenschwanz von problemen der da noch hinten dran steckt und das ganze halt auch noch getoppt mit man kann es heutzutage auf telefon so ohne die unterstützung von apple und google.
Nicht umsetzen.
Und du hast ich habe gerade mal überschlagen ich meine gut deine zehn millionen telefone waren glaube ich ein bisschen also.
Knapp ich glaube in in deutschland gibt es wahrscheinlich,
eher so hundert millionen telefone also mehr als ich glaube es gibt mehr telefone als als einwohner.
Ja gut aber du hättest nicht mehr von diesem system als einwohner.
Nee aber damit das erfolgreich funktioniert damit es was bringt wurden auch schon mal so raten von mir nicht fuffzig sechzig prozent ungefähr erreichen dann können wir es wahrscheinlich auch
er sein lassen ist der nutzen eher begrenzt ich meine wenn jeder nur jeder zweite drin ist sagen fällt halt jeder zweite weg
so
Und klar wenn es aber irgendwann ist sozusagen auch einfach der der den waren nutzen für dich wenn du nur sagen.
Quasi ich sage mal in bei bei zehn millionen telefon wird so nur jeden achten,
gefährlichen kontakt überhaupt erfassen können also bei der verbreitung glaube ich egal welche variante da kommt wird's
wird's problematisch aber.
Ich weiß worauf du hinaus willst du meinst es müssten eigentlich noch sehr viel mehr sein als diese zehn millionen.
Es müssten sehr viel mehr sein also eigentlich müsste man realistisch eher von vierzig millionen ausgehen
und wenn wir dann wenn wir jetzt also zehn millionen anfragen am tag haben sind es halt hundertfünfzig pro sekunde,
und ja das ist jetzt nicht so super viel so man kann das wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut parallele in der in der cloud also es sollte jetzt.
Also performance mäßig gut am am ende des tages je nachdem wie effizientes implementiert es ist auch nochmal ein problem aber der der der punkt ist halt mit hundert hundertfünfzehn anfragen.
Pro sekunde ist auch ganz schwierig zu die backen,
so ein system weil ich hab ich betreibe halt selber auch systeme da kommen halt so auch bis zu hundert request pro sekunde rein.
Und da braucht man erhebliche infrastruktur nochmal und software um überhaupt das system vernünftig betreiben und die banken zu können und ich würde mal sagen.
Bei dem ding wenn ihr das in sechs monaten am start haben so funktionierend dann ja waren sie schnell.
Ja
Ja so,
so also wer so meine einschätzung so das kann man nicht in einem monat runter hacken no way.
Vor allem mit einem riesen fell faktor also da kann einem auch konzeptionell in dem ganzen system design schnell mal was auf die füße fallen was nicht mehr richtig mit skaliert und dann muss man dann komplett wieder von vorne anfangen also das ist einfach wahnsinn.
Sechs monate bis zwei jahre würde ich würde ich sagen müsste es bis es läuft.
Ja sorry leute wir haben jetzt einen impfstoff na aber schön schön dass ihr euch dran gesetzt.
Ja ja.
Übrigens noch zu deiner these man braucht auf jeden fall sechzig millionen ich sehe das ja ein bisschen anders ne also.
Jenny.
Also man oder man braucht sechzig sechzig prozent okay.
Das war nicht meine these das hatte ich irgendwo gelesen.
Ja ja also das wurde auch diskutiert aber das nimmt sozusagen an das system hat nur dann einen nutzen wenn es sozusagen total ist ja wenn es alles erfasst aber.
Selbst wenn nur.
Zehn millionen leute in deutschland das machen oder sagen wir mal zehn prozent der leute das das machen was meiner meinung nach eine absolut realistisches ziel ist ja ehrlich gesagt bin relativ optimistisch dass man.
Locker auf dreißig prozent kommen kann und das dann mit der entsprechenden begleitung und vertrauensschaden und so weiter und vielleicht auch mit ersten erfolgen dann auch schnell noch gesteigert bekommt selbst wenn's weniger sind.
Jeder vermittelte kontakt hilft.
Egal wen du da erwischt jeder einzelne der gewarnt wird kann sozusagen identifiziert werden schneller identifiziert werden und leute können vor infektionen geschützt werden.
Aber der der der der nutzen natürlich steigt quadratisch mit der zahl
der der teilnehmer weil wenn jetzt nur jeder zehnte so eine app hat dann hat erstmal nur jeder zehnte überhaupt den nutzen davon und kriegt aber auch nur jeden zehnten kontakt
eingesammelt das heißt sagen der nutzen ist quasi der gesamt nutzen ist dann ein hundertstel hast du dagegen sagen die hälfte der leute die
die die app dann sammelt die hälfte der leute die hälfte aller möglichen kontakte ein hast du quasi nutzen von ein viertel jetzt pathetisch ja das heißt das ist halt auch
einfach eine problem dass der dass der nutzen halt wie das in vielen technischen system oder kommunikationssystem so ist
steigt halt überproportional mit der zahl der teilnehmer und in dem fall eben quadratisch.
Eine weitere exponentielle zahl mit der sich die bevölkerung mal beschäftigen kann und in der stelle ist es sogar nicht bedrohlich sondern sozusagen positiv besetzt weil du kannst mit einem einzelnen rettungsfahrten das medial schon mal ist ja auch.
Quadratisch quadratisch nicht nicht exponentiell also er ist der exponenten ist halt hoch zwei es fest.
Okay wie auch immer auf jeden fall steigt schneller an als linie und was sie eigentlich sagen wollte ist in dem moment wo du einen ersten fall hast wo jemand sagen kann ich wurde gewarnt ich war auch infiziert.
Ich bin habe sozusagen bevor ich selber symptome hatte einen test bekommen.
Und wurde als virus träger identifiziert das ist sozusagen die sexuelle story die du dadurch generieren kannst und wenn du die nimmst und sagst gucke mal funktioniert dann sagen sich alle anderen so oh ja.
Leben retten jetzt indem ich mir diese app installiere von der dann vielleicht alle sagen.
Unter normalen umständen vielleicht jetzt nicht so aber unter diesen umständen ist das okay.
Weil wir wissen dass die implikation die preis die implikation im rahmen ist ja es gibt da theoretische an chris vektoren aber die sind sehr theoretisch und es gibt da relativ.
Wenig bis kein missbrauchspotenzial.
Also was was allerdings vielleicht auch nochmal sozusagen meine diese sozusagen quadratische nutzen
rechnung die ich da aufgemacht habe zeigt natürlich auch wie wichtig das ist dass so ein system eine möglichst hohe akzeptanz hat
das heißt das sozusagen auch der nutzen des systems quadratisch mit seiner akzeptanz steigt,
und vor dem hintergrund natürlich ist halt der der nutzen einfach von einem system
gegen das widerstand besteht vor dem halt dann auch wahrscheinlich ein großer teil der fachärztlichen einfach warnen wird ist.
Eine tod geburt so sie hat abgesehen davon dass es in absehbarer zeit technisch nicht brauchbar nicht.
In einer hinreichendem qualität realisierbar ist in meinem haben wir ja bei toll collect gesehen
wie wenig es hilft jetzt große gruppen oder so dran zu setzen das ganze du kannst da vielleicht ein team von zehn oder zwanzig leuten dransetzen wenn du mehr dran setzt
an das ganze dauert es länger.
Es ist,
halt auch noch sagen dass das das ding und ja also meiner meinung nach ist das ganze tot
und wenn's nicht tot ist wird es ungefähr so eine erfolgsgeschichte wie der elektronische personalausweis.
Ja genau.
Ja hätte im prinzip was gekonnt aber keiner wusste es und es gab keine ordentlichen tools dafür und so weiter alles ein bisschen schwierig.
Der vollständigkeit halber um das thema vielleicht mal abzuschließen ich hatte ja schon angedeutet dass es da so eine so eine nationale brücke gibt
ja und das aber die franzosen da eine andere sachen machen das protokoll was ich jetzt hier besprochen habe dieses zentralisierte protokoll hat jetzt den namen in teka.
Bekommen von diesem protokoll projekt.
Viel zu viele ps und tees in diesem ganzen spiel mit drin also was die abkürzung ist für nie.
Extrem vertrauenserweckend finde sorgt.
Wir müssen das wirklich wissen jetzt in frankreich wiederum.
Soll dann sozusagen so eben der beschluss und dort gibt es wohl auch ein team was irgendwie an den implementierung sitzt aber aus irgendwelchen gründen.
Meinen die franzosen also sie wollen sozusagen dieselbe als mit also mit die franzosen ich weiß es nicht genau wie groß war die gruppe ist wie wie sehr der staat dahinter steht et cetera aber das ist sozusagen im prinzip dasselbe modell dort.
Heißt das projekt robert robustes irgendwas habe ich vergessen.
Und obwohl es technisch auf demselben modell aufbaut.
Sollen wohl diese its also diese letztlich vom server an die apps durchgereicht in all dies die dann versendet werden anders aufgebaut sein.
Wasser anders ist steht in diesem dokument was ich nur auf die deutsche implementierung bezieht nicht steht nur.
Anders und ich freue mich halt ja warum also warum muss das.
Anders sein also damit dann nur die franzosen wissen wie man diese wieder zurück berechnen kann damit die keiner weiß.
Ja okay das klingt plausibel zeigt aber dann auch gleich wieder
das da wieder so ein verborgenes angriffs faktor mit drin ist den man irgendwie beschützen muss durch irgendein wir erklären euch nicht genau wie es funktioniert modell das heißt es wird dann vielleicht darauf hinauslaufen dass das dann nicht so klar ist wie das berechnet wird wolltest keinem sagen also vertrauen schafft das auch nicht
und dass das dann irgendwie auch noch von anderen europäischen ländern auch alles nochmal separat implementiert werden soll das
da klappt ich dann irgendwie komplett zusammen ja so jetzt haben wir quasi die initiative des größten europäischen wirtschaftsstärksten und am wenigsten betroffenen landes dieser ganzen geschichte
und die werden sich dann schon ausreichend schwer tun und was wäre denn jetzt eigentlich die alternative es gibt jetzt schon für dieses google apple modell.
Gibt's schon aufgetan implementierung für so eine app viele leute haben sich weil ja die api schon spezifiziert ist von von von google apple
gibt es viele leute die schon gesagt haben so hier ich habe mal angefangen open source und hier wäre so mein.
Meine vorstellung wie ein interface aussehen soll wie die benutzerführung ist wie dieser ganze übergabe prozess gemacht wird und so weiter also wir sehen jetzt schon eine breite entwicklungsfonds und ehrlich gesagt ich habe auch relativ wenig zweifel dass wir,
zügig dort eine app sehen werden in den usa vorbehaltlich der problematik trump und so weiter also da gibt es sicherlich auch nochmal crash
potenzial ähnlich natürlich auch in die eigentlich so die natürlich ein partner dieser ganzen geschichte werden aber ich denke am ende wird sich da die technik einfach durchsetzen weil jetzt einfach alles ziel haben da agil schnell zum ziel zu kommen haben wir schon drüber gesprochen
viele gruppen alle offenes protokoll alles dokumentiert vor allem auch in einfacher sprache also ich hatte wirklich schwierigkeiten mich durch diese ganzen
durch diese whitepaper durch zu kurven muss sagen bis ich begriffen habe wie das funktioniert hat nachdem ich da irgendwie zwanzig seiten text gelesen habe.
Da war ich irgendwie mit dieser einen oder zwei seitenbeschreibung von diesem apple protokoll echt schneller bedient das war einfach,
es war einfach so ja hier wir machen das das ist der der der der der flow so geht das hin und her übers netz hier noch ein paar anmerkungen so funktioniert die crypto.
Fertig ach ja und hier ist noch die die hier natürlich nirgendwo zu finden ist und.
Das war's das das habe ich irgendwie an einem abend mal locker mal nebenbei mit bisschen vorwissen mir reinziehen können
und das wird einfach dazu führen dass wir da sehr schnell eine app infrastruktur sehen und dann wird sich dann irgendwo eine königsetappe durchsetzen da wird irgendwo einen ding kommen wo alle sagen.
Okay das nehmen wir auch passen wir für uns an.
Tragen wir unsere server ein unsere zertifikate ein haben wir nochmal eine spezifika wie wir das mit der meldung machen und dann unser tanksystem und so weiter das passt man dann innerhalb von ein paar tagen an
und dann wird die welt mit zwei oder drei verschiedenen apps im wesentlichen arbeiten also zumindest die westliche welt und dann läuft der hase und man hat irgendwie ein.
Oder apple baut das ich könnte mir auch vorstellen dass es in seine health app einfach mit einbaut das ist dann irgendwie keine ahnung.
Das werden sie nicht tun nein nein ich meine sie bauen ja jetzt schon den wichtigen teil in ihr u s rein es wird dieses framework.
Nicht sofort ich meine jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwie langfristig kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen aber.
Denkbar.
Es wäre tatsächlich noch nicht mal noch nicht mal nötig das schöne ist dass man tatsächlich sogar viele apps
haben kann in dem fall die aber einfach alle wunderbar miteinander harmonieren ist mir eine frage des user interface.
Das wird das wird nicht passieren aus zwei gründen erstens,
apple hat von vornherein ist also ich sage es immer apple und das gilt dann im prinzip genauso auch für google ne aber es gab die aussage zugriff auf dieser api gibt es nur für die apps von den national health organisations.
Also es ist nicht so dass jetzt hier eine neue abi und jetzt schick mal eure apps in store.
Also wenn wenn denn jeweilige hält service der meinung ist sie müssten mehrere apps anbieten ja dann vielleicht so aber an sich wird das nicht stattfinden.
Okay das ist nur eine organisatorische warum meinst du was ist das problem warum.
Das problem ist warum das überhaupt gar keine gute idee ist in meinen augen ist du musst ja in dem moment wo du eine warnung aussprichst mehr faktoren beeindruckt mit berücksichtigen als nur.
Dein subs system hat irgendwelche dies verglichen und die sind jetzt die matchen jetzt sondern du musst an der stelle auch psychologisch.
Richtig arbeiten wie warst du in welchem zeitlichen kontext also dieses whisky-sessions moment
das ist der begriff der in diesem ganzen papers dazu immer fällt dieses
ermittle ich jetzt wirklich welches konkrete risiko bei dir konkret vorliegt und wie vermittelt ich das das das die person nicht sofort in ohnmacht oder vor panik schrei so
kannst ja auch so ein countdown machen so sie haben noch zu leben eintausend sekunden auf null runter und so keine gute idee na also du willst sozusagen an der stelle dass.
Klar moderieren du willst kulturell passend haben du willst es auch in relation zu der aktuellen gesetzeslage und bedrohungslage und so weiter also da kommst du breiten ökosystem.
Das nicht dass nicht jeder hinz und kunz irgendwo so eine app an
bieten kann das ist mir schon klar aber es spreche jetzt nichts dagegen wenn
es tatsächlich unterschiedliche anbieter gibt die
mit demselben dienst zusammenarbeiten und ich sag mal von unterschiedlichen keine ahnung medizintechnik firmen oder wie auch immer und die halt dann natürlich
ja schon in den offiziellen segen irgendwo brauchen oder eine abnahme oder eine zertifizierung oder wie auch immer.
Am anfang ja wird es sicherlich sinnvoll sein irgendwie wenn sagen da die die eine app gibt die dann in dorsten wird.
Aber aus meiner sicht spricht jetzt nichts dagegen bei dem anderen system durchaus mehrere apps ich meine wird's ja auch geben
so weil wahrscheinlich verschiedene länder an der unterschiedliche apps mit irgendwie sprachen und so bis jetzt nicht
vielleicht gleich die in der app mit hundertsechzig sprachen bauen und kulturelle besonderheiten und so wie du schon richtig sagt ist aber mein punkt war nur grundsätzlich.
Wäre es möglich sagen auch mehrere verschiedene apps zu haben die alle das gleiche tun.
Weltweit ist das so aber ich glaube mehr als eine apropro land werden wir nicht sehen ich rechne auch damit dass diese apps sonderstatus bekommen in den appstores das apple sagen könnte oder auch google okay wenn's hier ein update gibt für diese app.
Muss der user gar nicht auf update klicken sondern wir forcieren das update egal wie die user settings sind.
Es wird einfach ein modus geben mit dieser app wird immer aktuell sein
wenn morgen neues assessment ist und die app muss darauf reagieren und das ändert sich etcetera p und es ist ganz ganz wichtig dass wir jetzt sehr schnell auf diese neue version umsteigen und das alle das haben dann
drücken die da einfach auf die turbo taste und dann dann fliegt das da einfach auf dein telefon drauf.
Geht das keine apple das kann apple.
Mit sicherheit können sie das also.
Also habe ich also ich hab's noch nicht gesehen so auch bei betriebssystems updates und so.
Sie können auch apps löschen und haben's noch nie getan selbst wenn sie es heute nicht können könnten sie es dann können also.
Ja
Wie gesagt ich sage nicht dass wird passieren ich sag nur ich werde null überrascht wenn wenn dieses feature auch kommen würde um sicherzustellen dass an dieser stelle wirklich das dressing weltweit einfach synchronisiert läuft
dass das einfach dass es nicht daran hakt dass die leute nach vier wochen dann mal auf den button drücken.
Gut da gibt es eine gibt es aber natürlich eine einfache variante dass du sagen wenn du die app
startest jetzt dann wird der halt einfach gesagt kannst du jetzt nicht benutzen weil brauchst die aktuelle version so das wäre wahrscheinlich die.
Oder so also irgendwas aber auf jeden fall wird das alles ganz guten support bekommen
na gut also ich bin gespannt vor allem also falls jetzt von den leuten die hier zugehört haben und diese paper auch gelesen haben wenn ihr da zu,
anderen oder weiteren erkenntnissen gekommen seid dann würde mich natürlich das extrem interessieren ja jetzt mal wieder disclaimer time ich habe das jetzt hier nach meinem
besten verständnis wiedergegeben ich habe mir relativ viel mühe gegeben das zu verstehen und irgendwie
in diesem einen fall zwanzig seiten dokument dann kommt nochmal irgendwie zehn also ich habe da wie wirklich relativ viel durchgeackert.
Kann gut sein dass wir da ein paar aspekte noch irgendwie abhanden gekommen sind aber im großen und ganzen glaube ich habe ich schon getroffen.
Ja es.
Pavel wollen wir mal zum ende kommen war wieder eine lange sendung.
Der menge holz es ist auch schon spät und erschöpfung macht sich breit.
Genau ja dann machen wir es einfach mal ganz kurz und,
vielen vielen dank fürs zuhören hier beim corona weekly nächste woche werden wir dann wieder schauen wie sich die lage verändert hat und ob es ein paar gute nachrichten gibt und was ich hier im ergeben hat und pipapo
ja und dann bis dahin.
Und und ich bin gespannt auf jetzt in meinem.
Meine tweets sind ganz schön rumgegangen ob vielleicht irgendjemand von den vielleicht mal drauf drauf reagiert oder vielleicht ja ein paar impulse
für den ein oder anderen davon ausgehen dass wir vielleicht ein paar
antworten auf die fragen kriegen die wir hier heute auch gestellt haben nämlich ja einfach besser verstehen wer sich wie
infiziert und wann und wo und das da mehr druck dahinter gepackt
wird dass die daten einfach besser werden so dass diese hoffnung habe ich und deswegen verbringe ich so viel zeit damit darüber zu reden und auch mir das selber anzugucken.
Genau so geht's mir auch und dann mach ich vielleicht auch mal was zum schluss was ich sonst eigentlich nicht mache
falls ihr der meinung seid dass hier unser wöchentlicher gedankenaustausch mit all den aspekt
auch noch was ist für andere leute dann sagt doch mal bitte weiter und nutzt die euch zur verfügung stehenden kanäle vielleicht auch andere leute hier mit den debatte einzulassen das würde mich sehr freuen
und ja vielen dank fürs zuhören nächste woche geht's weiter und so ich dazu komme gibt's vielleicht auch noch ein paar andere aspekt.
Rund um die krise hierbei u k w da weiß ich aber noch nicht ganz genau wann es weitergeht bis dahin sage ich.